thank you members
yes good evening everyone welcome to
this month's meeting of the scrutiny
panel
um also welcome to council Brian Council
faruki first time here tonight
and uh thank you to all the directors
and cabinet members for coming along as
well uh just a few housekeeping things
first if the fire alarm is activated
please vacate the offices down the main
staircase opposite the lifts in the
foyer assembly in holy Square on the
green and officers will assist us and
advise us when it's deemed safe to
return to the chamber would everyone
please present ensure that their mobile
phones are turned to silent and they're
not used to make or receive phone calls
why the meeting is in progress
please note that this meeting has been
live streamed for members of the public
the meeting will also be recorded and
subsequently broadcast on the internet
does anyone intend to film the meeting
this evening
and that's a note
let's move on to the next item I've
received one request to speak under 20.1
and that's for councilor manners under
item number four
I've not received any requests for
public speaking I know we've got some
members of the public but I've not
received any
requests so we move on to the agenda
apologies for absence I have one
apologize so far from councilor warro if
we got any more
apologies from councilor Pope and
councilor Deborah
thanks again
are there any Declarations of Interest
and that's a no okay so moving on to
item three uh to approve the minutes of
the overview scrutiny panel held on the
30th of May a copy of the minutes are
attached to the agenda pack uh everybody
had a chance to read them can I have a
proposer please I'll propose
of councilor Moore proposed no I wanted
to ask you okay sorry because mine
remembed please okay I do appreciate
that we can't reflect what every
councilor says Etc in the minutes but in
the discussion about prioritization I
did make the point at an early stage in
the uh discussion that in the light of
what we had learned during the of the
unscrutiny training
I felt that the uh scoring Matrix that
we had was too limiting and that we
should actually review The Matrix and I
had the feeling that I had support from
some of the other members in in that
respect and that isn't reflected in here
and we've gone ahead and used the
existing scoring Matrix and I just
wanted it recorded please that some of
us were not happy with the scoring
Matrix and at some appropriate point if
this wasn't the appropriate point at
some appropriate point it would be a
good idea for us to have another look at
that thanks Cass Austin Charles can we
share an amendment there for that and we
can come back to that on item number
seven of that discussion again a little
while so thank you
okay so moving on to oh sorry did I get
proposal that was counselor more and
anyone second I think answer the cup
thank you moving on to item number four
that's the cabinet
all members are going they're great
thank you that's right moving on to item
number four the cabinet member
presentation uh we've got our councilor
our leader along this evening to give
his presentation on his vision for the
council
yeah thank you chair and uh thank you
for this invitation to speak to the
committee I hope my voice is going to
hold up a bit better than it did last
Thursday I'm not used to that experience
but it was croaking a bit at the end of
the leaders report
um you will have heard heard me say some
of what follows at full Council last
week but I think it's important to
um present things in the round because
this is an opportunity to have more of a
conversation because of the limits on
what's possible there
as far as the new Administration is
concerned I think this is a great time
to be coming into office
um Louise Askew is going to talk to you
tonight about the leveling up program in
the Margate Town deal so I'm not going
to speak about them in any detail but
obviously they are a big part of what we
are aiming to deliver for thanet
if this capital investment is successful
which I believe it will be it will have
lasting benefits that go beyond the
scope of the six schemes themselves in
terms of jobs skills and the economy
they're inevitably going to be different
opinions about individual projects and
priorities and there are some challenges
but it's great to have the opportunity
two years on to be able to carry forward
ideas that were put together under the
previous labor Administration
this Capital funding and the similar
backing for thanet Parkway should give
us a platform or two platforms if you
like to move forward
but the main reason we Attract it is the
significant level of deprivation within
the district
we can't ignore the fact that we have
suffered from a major year-on-year
withdrawal of Revenue funding over the
last 13 years which has had a
significant effect on our ability to
deliver services to the standard that
our residents expect and that is now
being compounded by inflation
despite that I am full of optimism about
what we can achieve
one reason for that which the public in
general probably don't appreciate is the
talented people that we have working for
us including at senior levels
they have a level of commitment to this
district and the residents which I think
is probably unusual in a local Authority
they've had to deal with some difficult
and unusual challenges and some of the
public would probably ask where the
outcomes are to show how good they are
but part of that is a consequence of our
stretch they've been
we've got senior people coming into post
now who will relieve some of that but
the pressure to deliver is going to
continue including from the political
leadership
it's also a big advantage that we have
an experienced cabinet five out of six
members having been part of the previous
labor Administration
all of Aries kept neighbors have also
had a change of political control this
year and inevitably that has meant a
steep learning curve in some cases with
new councilors going straight into
executive roles but that isn't the
situation here and it has meant that
we've been able to hit the ground
running
that's obvious when it comes to our
housing Cabinet member Helen Whitehead
sitting next to me and you have some
specific housing projects on the agenda
tonight before they go to Cabinet next
week so I'm not going to go into those I
don't need to repeat myself on this
really but providing affordable housing
is absolutely at the top of our priority
list because it is the main thing we can
do as a district council to improve the
quality of people's lives
it's obviously a national problem which
needs a national solution but we can do
better and that's why as our first major
policy initiative we are making a major
increase in the council's plans to
provide housing for those who need it
starting with the 42 units that Spitfire
green But continuing over the next four
years we've set a target of 400 over
that period because that is what
officers are confident we can afford
within the business plan but if
circumstances change and we can go
further then we will
and it's not enough but it is enough to
make a difference and for the people on
our housing waiting list who will get
suitable Council accommodation as a
result it's a solution
it's fantastic we've been able to do
this just two months after taking office
and again I want to give full credit to
the housing and finance teams who've
made it possible because it's absolutely
what we want to do as a labor
Administration
you all know that councilor Whitehead
will continue to focus on housing issues
including the need for more in-house
temporary accommodation and the work of
the rise team which are also things
which have a big impact on individual
lives
like other areas we've had a steep rise
in the numbers of people made homeless a
significant personal detriment to
themselves but also and unlike Council
housing at a financial cost to Residents
generally since providing temporary
accommodation comes out of the general
fund affecting our ability to deliver
other Council services
there's no more nowhere that's more
important for us to deliver our services
and in terms of our ability to manage
the public realm because of the role
that plays in perception about our
district both for residents and visitors
and the effects it has on our economy
our coastline is a huge natural asset
but the focus on managing the visitors
that this attracts and the heavy
footfall areas in our town centers
unless some of our residential areas
show and even Town centers suffering
from an unacceptable level of graffiti
in particular
one of our election pledges was to put
more street cleaners back in residential
areas and I'm pleased to say that we
will be doing that immediately starting
on Monday using Mali that isn't that is
already in the base budget but hadn't
been committed
we haven't got all the staff yet but the
plan is to have two new teams of four
who will work seven days a week from 10
in the morning until six at night across
the district's residential areas until
the end of October
we also said that we would significantly
Step Up removal of graffiti and fly
tipping and make bulky waste collections
more affordable and we will
members will be aware that there's a new
head of cleansing Services starting next
week and these are areas that we will
want him to look at and come up with a
plan as soon as practical
we already have the new motorized street
cleaning machines but sometimes you have
to recognize that problems come down to
the number of people you employ not just
how they are deployed
we argued for more street cleaners in
the current budget the conservatives
voted that down and now we are an
Administration that we're delivering on
what we said we would do
of course it's unrealistic to claim we
can solve all the problems entirely but
we can do better we want people to feel
better about the places where they live
and where there are still issues that
the council is aware of them and is
doing its best to address them
I also want to create better mechanism
for better mechanisms for groups of
residents to let us know when they still
feel that we're failing falling short in
things like street cleaning and waste
collection in their area
improving that dialogue with residents
and creating a more human face for the
council alongside more focus on delivery
is all part of building trust and
enabling us to work more collaboratively
we also need to look at our processes
including around asset disposal to
improve the way we engage with residents
the new head of legal and democracy will
be bringing forward proposals for
changes to the constitution in line with
the recommendations made by the
independent monitoring officer and we
need to think about what opportunities
there might be there but with the public
I don't think it's primarily about what
happens at formal council meetings I
think it's about culture
we have a good mix of counselors
including a number of new members who
are going to bring a fresh perspective
to Old problems
we're going to be talking a lot about
the towns and about Margate and Ramsgate
in particular because of the combination
of deprivation and the current
opportunity there but to be successful
we need to engage members across the
council and across the district because
it's not just about one part of Planet
at the expense of another all the views
of one political group
as their time allows I want a program of
Ward visits by senior officers to see
the issues firsthand and listen to
members views on what is needed and I
want to start that in wards where we
have new councils
to help build up their knowledge and the
officer relationships that will help
them serve their residents
I do think we saw benefits from some of
the collaboration and cross-party
working that happened between 2019 and
2023 and I don't want that to be lost
obviously we will have our differences
and I accept that it's the opposition
councilor's roles to hold us to account
but there are also plenty of things that
we can work on together
climate change is an obvious one
Rob Yates will be leading on this and
chairing the cabinet Advisory Group
which has already done some really good
work over the last few years it's an
issue that needs to be fully embedded in
everything we do and I don't want us to
be in a position of having to approve
another set of diesel vehicles because
we haven't put in place the
infrastructure that we need
we don't however live in a limitless
Utopia where every problem can be
resolved to the mutual satisfaction of
groups of residents with conflicting
concerns and we don't exercise Sovereign
power over what happens in thanet and
the limitations of the planning process
are a good example of that we can only
make decisions within the policy
framework Etc set by central government
a district council can only seek to
influence Westminster the County Council
the NHS the police the utility companies
and all the other private companies that
operate here which is what we will try
to do in the interests of our residents
I want us to be outward facing and
collaborating with and learning from our
neighbors because we can also have a
louder voice with those external bodies
if we operate as a region
finally I know members will be anxious
for answers on specific issues and we
don't have all of those yet we're about
to embark on the process of putting
together a new corporate plan that will
go through various stages of public
debate including overview and scrutiny
and it gives every member the
opportunity to contribute to setting the
council's priorities for the next four
years
if we do it right then everybody should
have a sense of ownership over the final
document and I'm looking forward to
hearing from Members across the council
about what they think should be in there
thank you for listening
thank you thank you leader
um speaking under 20.1 I've got Council
of men as I know you've got a question
I'm not sure if your question was
answered during that presentation do you
want to you want to make your question
yeah thanks
thank you chair
um in common with uh many other members
here I visited the leveling up funding
Exhibition at Ramsgate Harbor on Tuesday
and it was a really good opportunity to
see the details on the proposed projects
in one place
I believe we'll welcome the Regeneration
to the harbor area and the valuable
amenity it stands to bring to the wider
Community but I'm concerned that the
quality and viability of delivery of
these projects may be undermined by
inflation since funding was earmarked at
the same time I'm mindful that the fact
that 3.4 million approximately is
allocated to Ramsgate Port
railroad infrastructure from the
leveling up funding this is money in
addition to the millions already spent
in pursuit of a roro ferry operator as
losses pile higher at the Port whilst
the council searches for an operator
where is the justification please for
spending even more money why not ring
fence the 3.4 million to be spent only
once contracts are irrevocably exchanged
on a deal to operate the port before
potentially throwing 3.4 million of good
money after bad
with that in mind has any approach been
made to the Secretary of State for
leveling up to allow cross funding
between projects to use this money to
support the underfunding in other
leveling up projects
I've also been unable to find accounts
that show any app the proper
apportionment apportionment of overhead
at the Port relevant to running a
proposed railroad operation where are
these figures please how much has been
spent to date in pursuit of a row row
operation what are the accounting
principles used in the calculation of
this figure
can members be allowed access to them
it seems Unthinkable and I'm sure I'm
hopeful it's not the case but we should
have a thorough grasp of all of the
costs of this operation before in order
to understand an in negotiation with a
potential operator
do we actually now have agreed heads of
terms from a bona fide
port or Ferry operator that show a
profitable viable commercial Port taking
into account properly apportioned
overhead finally given the leader's very
laudable statement to council last week
promising a fresh look at the way we do
things should this now not apply to the
port stop spending money ring fence the
3.4 million and if no terms have been
agreed by the end of 2023 then draw a
line under the uh the the the the the
process and pulls to re-examine all our
options on the port as an asset thank
you
well uh leader over to you there's quite
a lot of questions there I'm not sure
that they really fit into the context of
what I was asked to bring it I mean you
won't be surprised that I can't give you
a detailed breakdown of the financial
situation in relation to the port over
recent years
um I I assume that the previous
conservative leader was very happy to
proceed since she brought the proposal
to cabinet and cabinet voted for it in
terms of the ferry operation
um I think councilor manners is slightly
misunderstanding where we are in the
process
um we have invited expressions of
interest in operating the port I can't
say too much about that and because
they're confidential but I I will say to
him that both um I think councilor Ashby
I think I can speak for her on this and
myself were extremely confident that the
council would secure an operator and I
think the indications that we've
received have made me even more
confident that but councilor manager is
going to have to be a little bit more
patient I think it will be a very
strange thing for us to do to Halt the
process at this stage and having gone
all the way down the line and having
this this interest I think you're just
gonna have to be a bit patient in terms
of some of the information I'm sure if
you write to officers they'll be able to
give you some of the harder detail I
don't think it I can try and do that in
the context of this meeting and
obviously MS ask you is now here and
she's going to speak about leveling up
later on so I'm sure she'll address some
of the issues you've mentioned
uh thanks leader uh right over to
members of the panel for questions for
our leader
anybody got any questions uh all hands
up at the back there Council of green
thank you
um
the street cleaning teams is good news
at last thank you
um I guess though there's just two teams
so we'll have to be patient
before these teams get around to any
individual
Ward is there going to be a schedule or
are they going to be priorities
set
yeah I mean some of this is obviously
operational decision making
which is really a matter for officers
but I can say that
the brief that we gave officers we
wanted them working in residential areas
and we wanted it prioritized around
where we'd identified the need to be
greatest I mean I think um
we're not quite there yet but I think
having two groups of two two teams of
four people working seven days a week
across the district is going to make an
impact people are going to see these
people and they're going to see the
benefit of the work that they're going
to do and the great thing is that this
is base budget funding so you know it's
sustainable and obviously one would hope
that at the end of the summer period at
the moment we obviously have to put
significant resources into the tourist
areas which is
one of the reasons why we can't deliver
the service we'd like to be delivering
in the residential areas but this should
enable us to do this through to the end
of October and then we'll see where we
go but um yeah I think it's great news
and I hope that the residents will see
an improvement and I'm sure if they
don't they'll let us know
Council Austin
thank you chair
um on the um on the point that Council
of green made which is not the thing I
was going to ask about
um way back in the day when we first set
up the Ramsgate litter Forum there were
schedules street cleaning schedules that
residents could look at that told them
how often they could expect their street
to be cleaned I don't know how long they
that that was the case but it certainly
did exist and it would be of interest to
see if we could get something of the
kind again so that people knew
realistically
how high a priority their their street
or their area was anyway that wasn't
what I was going to ask what I was going
to say was this sounds really
encouraging and I'm very impressed by it
particularly I like the working with the
neighboring councils and the whole
business about making ourselves more
user-friendly to Residents and getting
more of a dialogue going
what I wanted to ask you was in four
years time when you're looking back on
This this term of office what are you
hoping will will have happened
particularly to deprivation in in this
area how will we have made a difference
to the level of deprivation in thanet
yeah I mean thanks for your your point
about um street cleaning schedules I'm
not quite sure that residents are really
that interested in some kind of bus
timetable of when there's when the
street cleaner is going to come along as
much as that they're actually going to
get their streets clean but we'll talk
about that
um yeah I think that there are a number
of factors I mean this Council on its
own can't address the deprivation issues
in this District I mean clearly national
government and the state of the economy
plays a big role in that I think that
the things that we're doing in terms of
the Regeneration opportunities should
drive some positive change you know I
think we can see we would like to see
you know we've got that we've got higher
um we've got the highest level of
unemployment in Kent you know we've got
a lot of youth unemployment soon we
would like to see those figures move
down towards the average for Kenya
obviously we'd like to eliminate it
completely but we don't live in a
perfect world and I think the things
that we're doing will support that you
know I'm I'm you know I'm biased
obviously because I'm in Newington
counselor but I'm a hugely enthusiastic
about the leveling up initiative in
Newington and I think it's a good
example of somewhere where I know that
the Newington community center team
really wanted to do the project
themselves and they had an idea about
what they wanted and they were let's be
honest a little bit suspicious about the
council wanting to deliver it and now
they've seen the what the council was
put forward with the help of the
Consultants obviously they're absolutely
Blown Away by it so they're really
excited by the way the council was
engaged with them over that so you know
that's a fantastic example of something
we can achieve
um yeah I think that you we want to see
the indicators moving in the right
direction don't we and we want to see
people people feeling better about
thanet and we want to see you know the
district to be more prosperous overall
it's hard to put metrics on it
that's a bite
hi and thank you Rick for your your
informative
um Talk I'd like to Echo um what
councilor Wing was saying
um about the the commute uh sorry
Council Austin I'll do it I do apologize
uh I'd like to okay what councilor
that's a great start isn't it
um what what councilor uh Austin was
saying about the um about the the
scheduling I think you know if you're
not in and people have cleaned your
street they haven't cleaned your street
and as far as you know I actually think
would it be would it be possible to have
some dialogue maybe with the
communications teams here so that there
is a way of letting people know that you
know street cleaning is coming it's
coming in your area and when that might
be because you know I think all of us
already particularly new councils are
kind of you know that's the number one
issue on people's minds at the moment
and actually I think half the battle is
is clear Communications
um and it'll be really really helpful so
is it possible maybe to speak with
someone in the communications team about
having a strategy for making sure that
people are aware of the good work that
we do because it's not all bad news
I'm aware certainly I mean I think we
want to create awareness and and
visibility for the teams doing this work
but um I mean one of the challenges
obviously is that that you don't want an
equal amount of street cleaning resource
in each ward in each area because the
reality is that the the need for it is
much greater in some areas than it is in
others so you don't simply apportion the
resource out equally between the 23
wards
um on its most simplistic level if you
had it wouldn't be sensible to have 23
members of Staff one of them working in
each Ward because there are some walls
that would require four or five times as
much whether because they're on the
seafront they're in the tourist areas or
they're just you know they have
particular issues
um so I'm a bit skeptical about all that
but I'm sure it's something we can talk
about outside the meeting and I'm sure
that um
I'm sure that Mr Humber would have a
view on it and um and the staff in the
operations area would have review
thank you our Council Davis
uh good evening later um I very much
welcome the news on the on the uh the
Boost to the social housing numbers
because unlike uh some who wear my
colors uh I am actually a big believer
in the necessity for this
um I do have a couple of questions as I
say the questions and critiques rather
than being critical at this point
um
whilst it's very nice to get a standard
of property that we're obviously looking
for and I'm not I'm not suggesting there
should be anything less
um rather a developer will always have a
profit element would we not be better
off doing as we've done elsewhere
perhaps and building more of our own
rather than going out to developers
because again and I and I I don't know
enough about the history of this but
were these subjects who attend a process
or was the council approached with this
because I think it's the way forward for
the council and private developers to
work together it's just this seems to
have come up very very quickly on us and
there's a lot of questions about how
it's afforded and the 18-year payback
and that so
um I think it's a good principle but but
there are questions which I think
everyone would like the answers to but
I'm trying not to sound too sort of
judgmental or aggressive on this it's
just a very interesting Avenue to
explore was it a tender process or
I think um
I think uh Council Davis that
um all those sort questions can be
answered in in yeah I think I think
councilor Whitehead's gonna have plenty
of time to take those sort of questions
yeah apologies didn't mean to steer off
there sorry but but a very welcome
initiative to add to those numbers
indeed
well I mean yeah I don't want to still
counselor what is thunder either but I
mean I think that you're absolutely
right that we would like to be building
more of our own properties but but first
of all you have to find the land for it
um and secondly you have to
um all the problems we build after I
have to be for 40 subsidy so that
subsidy has to come from somewhere
um so even if we um
in the case of the developers it comes
from the developer because the developer
provides that provides the property at
40 off the market value to the council
um this wouldn't be any good if it was
simply than it District Council
replacing a Housing Association and
taking over a 106 property on a
development
what we're actually doing as Helen will
no doubt explain is buying
properties which have been assigned as
section 106 are they should be used for
affordable housing which developers do
not want uh sorry housing associations
do not want because the local housing
associations are particularly moved on
to bigger schemes they don't want to buy
these small pockets of housing so what
would happen in those cases is that
there'd be a challenge eventually
to the planning consent and those houses
would probably the developer would try
to put them on the market probably and
sell them so what we're trying to do is
add to the total you're absolutely right
though that building our own houses and
being in control of our own house is a
better situation but we need to have the
land to do it and the finances need to
stack up the finances for this stack up
you know there's been a lot of work done
around that and I'm sure councilor wired
will go into it
Council Wing thank you I've got a number
of questions sorry leader but I will
start by saying our two street cleaners
in Ramsgate absolutely deserve gold
medals they do an incredible job
whenever I see them I thank them for
what they're doing uh they do do you
know in in difficult circumstances a lot
of the time they I never see them sat
they're always doing something so
although we've only got a few street
cleaners the ones we have in Ramsgate
have always been top drawer I have to
say uh I and I'm glad that rubbish is is
a key issue because I think we all
remember door knocking and speaking to
locals and some of the key priorities
that people had were around tidy streets
Safe Streets and toilets uh and I don't
actually think our residents are asking
an awful lot and I'm not quite sure how
we're not able to deliver that but I
think there needs to be some joined up
thinking King Street is a particular
problem in Ramsgate every Friday born in
King Street and High Street I drive past
a massive amount of rubbish that is
normally some households not managing
their own waste have we got away is
there dialogue between our street
cleaners who are obviously out of the
chalk face
and then passing that information back
to Street Scene because also Street
Scene do an incredible job and I've
reported landlords and homeowners that
are not managing their rubbish and it
just it that there could be an easy way
of
shortcutting the system by by
encouraging the street cleaners to
actually give that intelligence back to
Street Scene that can come out in force
going on to toilets I drive past I drive
past most mornings the Margate Porter
toilets and I they're always horrible
things to use you've got to be
absolutely desperate I believe to use a
pool to pull to toilet but it struck me
that have we ever done a cost saving of
comparing how much we pay to have those
toilets there for a year against
actually refurbishing I think it's a
clock house toilets in Margate uh you
know I I I know that four toilets on
Addington Street for a day of 400 pounds
for the day is there some sort of cost
saving to actually investing in
refurbishment of proper toilets that I'm
absolutely certain visitors and uh our
own residents would prefer them rather
rather than using a pool to potty
uh uh uh do you want to answer questions
then I go to the next one leader or
shall I just bombard you with all the
questions I mean
canceling I mean I'll be disappointing
if you didn't have questions to ask me
but I
I think that possibly your
misunderstanding the purpose of this
session in the sense that I'm was asked
to give a vision which is fairly
elevated and I've tried to talk on a
higher level and obviously I'm not going
to be able to give you uh precise
details about costings of toilets in
Margate what I can tell you is the
toilets are priority for this
Administration that we've been talking
about them this afternoon that the
council's conducted a conditioned survey
of all its public toilets and we have
some information about what it may cost
us to do the required works for them and
I've asked Mr Humber to come forward
with a paper in September to cabinet so
that you can see all that information
and that there's a plan
thank you you're you're operating a high
level I'm sowing seeds and bringing us
down to what things would look like for
residents
kin is another key issue that I really
do think we need to address and I
welcome that the parking review that's
coming forward uh and so I'm hoping that
will make a real difference to not just
residents but to visitors and I saw to
favor parking residence parking schemes
going back to the pool you know I have
worries and concerns about uh us being
able to to uh bring a ferry in and
actually the discussion was very much
about cargo there wasn't much mention of
of Ferry a ferry a passenger Ferry
coming in which would be sad because I
loved the Sally line uh but I do worry
we're a small pool we don't necessarily
have the facilities I don't believe in
the building and they will come scenario
because we've already refurbished the
row row and nobody's come we presently
have birth four and four four and five
still not functional I don't I'd still
not operational we don't have full
costings and Brett's clearly haven't put
a planning application to put the said
conveyor on top of that birth
so I worry that we I worry as uh the
council spoke under 20.1 that we are
going to waste a great deal of money and
I'd like to see the evidence behind our
decision making so you know you invest
so many millions and you expect
not an immediate return on those
Millions but you certainly would have
probably made some prediction
predictions forward if you bring X in it
will have this benefit if you bring Y in
it will have this benefit so I'd
certainly welcome a bit more about the
ability to scrutinize how the evidence
how the decision have been made I also
think it's really important for us to
con to to have in the back of our head
the findings of of the review of births
four and five uh I certainly think there
are key principles there that we need to
use on all the major spends moving
forward otherwise we're just going to
make a number of mistakes again and of
course I'm really concerned that we
follow all the planning and
environmental legislation and
assessments in order to protect people
and places I have deep concerns about
the lack of dust monitoring on that site
and I spoke at planning about the the
noise and vibration monitors were
between the houses and the dust monitors
were a thousand meters behind the
housing and we still have residents with
concerns about dust in their houses none
of us are experts we need some proper
dust assessment and we certainly if
we're going to allow Brits to expand
that assessment of dust needs to be
undertaken so that we can be absolutely
certain that we're not exposing people
to harmful substances thank you
I think I want a guarantee I'm not a
guarantee I want us to apply the
findings of the review of birth four and
fives because there was there were some
very important lessons that were learned
there and we'll put down in that review
one of them was we knew we needed an
environmental impact assessment right
way back in 2014-15 there's going to be
a lot of development on that pool and I
want to be in I want to be certain that
we are going to put in place and and
take measures to protect people and
places and that means following the
highest level of planning and
environmental assessment we possibly can
and I'd just like that to be
guaranteed if you like
can you guarantee that councilman well
all I can tell you is that all the
conversations I've had with Mr Humber
will reassure me that everything that we
do at the Port is being tested legally
and and you know will be an entirely
proper process
um so I'm confident about that I mean we
I sort of understand I do understand why
there is a lot of skepticism about the
council's ability to attract a ferry
operator to the pool because there have
been a number of abortive engagements
with some uh businesses who who I didn't
follow through on their plans and their
approaches
um but I'll repeat you know
both councilor Ashby and myself and I
know because I've discussed this with
her while we've been leaders of the
council are aware of numerous approaches
from major organizations who want to use
Ramsgate port
and my understanding is that the
expressions of Interest we have invited
have produced a similar outcome but I
obviously can't tell you anything of the
substance of that and in fact I don't
know the substance for that because it's
not appropriate for me at this point to
know it
but I am absolutely confident that there
is a that there will be an operation
from Ramsgate Port using the new
infrastructure and the reason why it
couldn't happen previously is because we
didn't have that infrastructure in
particular we didn't have the Border
infrastructure and we would not put it
in place on a speculative basis unless
the unless the operators were prepared
to make a commitment to us to say we
could make sure that the council will be
out of money we weren't going to do that
you know and we weren't able to do it on
the basis on the speculative basis that
we were approached before what we've got
now is a process in which somebody will
take on responsibility for running the
pool they will deal with whoever's
coming in and out they will take the
risk on that this is going to happen it
is going to happen and I really don't
think we need to keep going over the
same ground
in terms of what's happened before
because
sometimes you have to have a little bit
of trust and I think this process you
will see at the end of this process why
we've been so committed to this
particular route for the Paul
okay so I've got Council Council Davis
councilman councilor Brighton I think we
just wrap that up after
thank you leader for uh your vision
um as many you said I think it's
exciting and um I look forward to
keeping you accountable of that and make
sure that you deliver all those those
items the thing that I wanted to ask
about was
um as I'm sure you know and are aware of
um the Youth of thanet is something
incredibly important to me and
um you know it's one of my proudest
things that we were able to set up the
youth Council
um and I just wanted you to if you could
just explain where you think in your
vision the youth Council sits and what
you would like to see of the
um youth involvement within the council
as well moving forward to ensure that
we're not just delivering for people
with the older generation or middle aged
but also ensuring that there are the
opportunities for younger people as well
thank you
yeah the youth Council I think was a
good initiative Council it happened I
know councilor Keane is very
enthusiastic about it I know the
officers are very enthusiastic about it
and we want to look at the ways that we
can take it Forward I know there's been
a discussion about whether in future we
could involve members of the youth
Council in our cabinet advisory groups
um that might be a bit dry and Dusty I
don't know
um but I think it's really about up to
the young people themselves as to how
they want to engage with us we can give
them opportunities and we can see what
which way they want to take it forward
but I certainly think that they are a
hard to reach group for the council in
terms of you know we're not going to get
responses to our surveys from from young
people
um probably anybody under 50 I should
think the way these things go at the
moment and we've got to be more
inventive in terms of how we communicate
with young people and the youth council
is a good start but it's just a start
Council Davis
I'm going to mention the port but on a
slightly different basis to normal
because it's quite clear I'm sure to
everybody that there's huge concerns
about various different aspects and we
can sit here and backwards and forwards
all night over those concerns however
as well as importance there's always
priorities that come into things as well
and in a previous Incarnation as leader
there had been discussion about the risk
of well we talk about London waste but
waste from anywhere being shipped
through Ramsgate
um in order to feed various biomass
burners and that
um would you give the same commitment
that you gave previously as leader that
that will not happen on your watch
yes thank you very much
councilman Moore
yes thank you Chan thank you leader for
your briefing
um the question is I the two questions I
have for you is that regarding
um the street cleaning
um it's all brilliant that we've got
these uh two teams going but hand in
hand we have enforcement as well and on
councilor Wing did did strike that areas
very briefly but if we do find people
that are
blatantly fly tipping and and causing
this rubbish you know by enforcement
that's a positive way for us to even
deter that which means our street
cleaners don't have so much work so can
you not proportion some of that money
towards the enforcement team so that
they are more proactive and able to do
their work because I know they're
overworked as well because it's a small
team but if we could look at that as
well that would be very helpful and my
second question was regarding toilets
whether you can confirm or
um quash the rumor that one of the
reasons that the local toilets are being
shut early is that the contractors that
are doing this have to be back at their
Depots by certain times which is why
they are in unable to stay open as late
as they should be and if that isn't the
case can we quash that but if it is the
case can we look into that as a matter
of urgency because some of our local
toilets are being shot far too early
when people are still out and about and
it's important that we have these
facilities for our visitors and tourists
thank you
now my understanding is that is that the
issue of certain toilets shutting early
is about sequencing it's about a small
number of people who are going around
closing them they can't close they can't
clean and close them all at once I'm not
aware of any issues about people having
to be back at the Depot by
a time which is causing those particular
toilets to shut early I mean clearly
people have a they have a working day
and they're working day ends at some
point but I don't think that's I don't
understand that to be the cause of
things no
in terms of uh enforcement I mean we're
aware because we talked about it that
one of the things that slows down the
clearing of fly tipping is the need to
look at the fly tipping and see whether
there's any evidence that we can extract
from it to try and pursue the people
who've left it so that is a challenge
but this initiative that we're doing
here yeah it will address flight living
but it's not just about fly tipping it's
about lots of other things it's about
litter you know it's it's about some of
the real problem areas that we've got so
um yeah more enforcement would be great
more of everything will be great
um but let's see where we go with it
and lastly counselor
um just wanted to come back to your
point on um working closely with town
councils as well I think that's really
welcome
um and thank you already to Steve to
councilor Alvin for agreeing to meet
with
um with myself and the town clerk at
broadstairs to discuss
um the the gardens and the street scene
um absolutely welcomed
um
I guess my question is can we make sure
that we encourage that to be the case on
on the officer's side as well so is
there a way that we can make sure that
officers are as open to communicating
with our Town Council staff
um and respond to emails I guess that's
uh if there's if there's any influence
you can bring to bear on that that would
be very welcome
you know I think that's the direction of
travel I think the council
recognizes the role of the town and
Parish councils in taking on some of the
um responsibilities which in the past
the district councils carried out that
it can be better done at a local level
it could be it can be more fine-tuned
and
meet the needs of residents better so I
don't know why we would not want to
encourage that communication I'm sure we
would and you know if that's a problem
if it proves to be a problem then it's
something we can talk about but I'm I'm
sure that the the attitude of officers
will be the same as the attitude of
members
marvelous thank you
yeah yeah thank you for bringing that up
yeah so I mean obviously members will
know last term we've put together a
paper which which I asked you about at
full Council the other night whether
that's going to be taken to cabinet
which is not on the next agenda but
hopefully will be August well I don't
know looking at you
well well I'm slightly dependent on Mr
Hughes actually I mean he could probably
give you a better idea than me as to
when it's likely to come forward
uh with uh it's currently with the chief
executive
I'll just keep passing it around so yeah
I mean to answer councilor brights uh
some of the questions there that we
produced a paper in the last uh scrutiny
uh committee and there's all sorts of
recommendations we made with Parish
forums they're increasing channels of
communication with Turner parish
councils and officers so all those sort
of things that you're asking hopefully
will improve and and for the benefit of
Turner Parish councils which I'm a
member of as well
one quick one it's supposed to positive
I mean lots of
actually uh refurbished and looked after
by our volunteers and there's very much
an informal support from TDC workers
because there's a mutual respect for
helping each other out basically because
as you said most of us live here is are
there any plans to try and further
support volunteer groups to undertake
work
or or is are there any plans to maybe
formalize it so that volunteer groups
have got somebody that they can go
directly to to ask for bag deliveries to
act to maybe maximize outputs for TDC
and for Resident and for volunteer
groups
yeah I think McCaskey might be able to
help in that in terms of in terms of our
terms of the volunteer groups that are
out there working in the community
people in the third sector I'm certainly
very enthusiastic about
um harnessing the value of the
volunteers and I think the council could
do more to support and encourage them
there are challenges within that in
terms of
where the demarcation lines are
obviously as we want to we want we
volunteers are fantastic
um but at the end of the day if
volunteers stopped doing something
because they no longer they move away or
they're no longer available quite often
you find that projects lapse and that's
the challenge I think in terms of
um that's why in the end it's better to
have paid staff to pick litter up and
and I absolutely uh you know applaud all
the efforts of all the volunteer
litmakers across the district
um but we wouldn't want the district's
litter picking resource to be entirely
volunteers would we we don't we'd always
want we'd always want we'd always want a
core or permanent staff to deliver the
core service
um so but I think there are ways we can
work we can work better together you
know I I think I think you know
a directory of volunteer groups is very
much something that we should all have
access to but how we're how and when we
can put that together I can't give you
an answer at the moment
okay thank you members uh thank you
leader for coming along and answering
those questions I know you're always
very approachable but um I know
opposition members normally only get
that one once a month three minute
question to to uh to ask you about is
thanks for coming along this evening
answering everyone's questions thank you
okay moving on to item number five which
is the purchase of 42 Homes at Spitfire
green for affordable rent I will call on
Mr Porter who is a director for housing
to introduce the report and then I think
councilor Whitehead will take over
thank you very much chair um yeah I'm
going to say a few words of introduction
to talk through some of the background
to this and how the funding model works
and then I'll pass over to councilor
Whitehead who wants to speak about the
report as well
um so firstly so you'll all know that
Council last week
um considered a report setting out
proposals to deliver 400 homes over four
years a fundamental part of that
proposal is that around about 60 of the
cost of that program will come from
borrowing within the council's housing
revenue account and around about 40 40
will come from subsidy of one form or
another
and if you work the members briefing
that I gave at the beginning of last
week I said that that subsidy could come
from a number of different sources
including the use of our right to buy
receipts Grant from homes England or
subsidy from of it sector developers
where there are section one or six
agreements in place
this particular proposal the subsidy is
coming from the developer and the homes
are identified within the section 106
agreement as being for affordable homes
for rent
um
I think one of the key things to
um say about what in about identifying
which schemes we want to progress is
something that the leader I think
touched on in the presentation is that
we don't want to be competing with our
Housing Association Partners we very
much see housing associations as a part
of the supply of affordable homes
working alongside the council and we
don't want to be competing with them
but we can add value by taking projects
that housing associations don't want to
or are unable to deliver in their own
business plans
um so so this particular proposal what
Spitfire green is the first one of those
400 to deliver 42 homes for affordable
rent we have developed with colleagues
in finance an assessment tool to help us
check the viability of each project that
we bring forward to ensure that it
covers its costs within the business
plan period and to work work out the
point where the cash flow moves into
Surplus and in this particular case it
moves into Surplus in year 18.
um in the initial years and I think this
is the bit that
limits our ability to do as many of
these projects as we want in the initial
years there's a negative cash flow
position
um
and in this project that negative cash
flow in year one is 54 000.
but we have been setting aside
funding each year from the affordable
rented homes we've already delivered
thank you
um from the affordable homes you've
already delivered to help subsidize the
program and we've got a budget of 300K
per annum already within the approved
budgets so that we're covering the cost
of that cash flow deficit in the initial
years from that 300 000.
um
there was a question about costs which I
might since I know you're going to ask
it I'll deal with it now
um the the costs of our the next phase
of our new build program
um when there's about four sites in the
program that have already been approved
and already funded for the council Zone
construction program the costs of those
units are about 3 200 pounds per square
meter
and obviously
um you know build cost inflation is
infecting affecting everybody uh in
including us and including developers
um we've just been checking the
specifications for the 14 42 units
that's Spitfire green and the assessment
of market value for those homes is
around 3 200 pounds per square meter so
um there's not actually that much
difference in cost it's pretty much the
same provided we can secure subsidy for
our program that we're building and the
program that we're we're acquiring
um
so I hope that gives some some comfort
and actually the program over time will
include both of those models
um and um you know if we're going to get
to 400 we need to take all the
opportunities that come our way that
Stack Up
um I think that's probably all I want to
say about the funding arrangements and
what we're delivering and I'll pass over
to council Whitehead
thank you Mr Porter
and and thank you members for having me
here to talk about this
um I am somewhat unsurprisingly utterly
passionate about this item and with very
good reason
our housing situation is in terms of our
records already extraordinarily
challenging
our list currently stands at 1604
households
the even more unfortunate fact is that
our numbers certainly underestimate the
scale of need
all individuals on our list are all
individuals with an identified and
documented need for housing
the actual number of households who
require support in accommodation in
terms of rent affordability and
suitability of housing is without doubt
much higher
every day I receive more and more
housing cases relating to housing
suitability rent Rises temporary housing
and continuing housing stresses related
to the cost of living crisis
and to address that we need to start
from a literal foundational level
rental rates across Planet are
increasing rapidly as our eviction
notices
properties that five years ago cost
around 600 pounds a month on our
routinely marketed for over 1 200.
and as I find myself saying frequently
regeneration without infrastructure such
as genuinely affordable housing is
simply displacement
they should not and will not be the
future of our community
these challenging times do require skill
and creativity and luckily we have these
in abundance within our housing team
I always speak highly of Housing and
with exceptionally good reason
their ambition and commitment is
extraordinary and the work that went
into enabling this is a perfect example
housing have an extra established track
record of successfully delivering new
genuinely affordable rented homes and an
absolute commitment to delivering
we are competent confident and committed
to providing for our residents
but we need to do more and deliver what
is needed quickly
and I'm delighted to be able to
introduce this report that sets out our
ambition and our methods to deliver over
400 new affordable homes for rent over
the coming four years
a huge increase on our previous delivery
rates
to reference councilor Davis question
earlier this is very much a mixed
delivery including our own high
specification developments with future
plans for growth and Energy Efficiency
and delivery via you unused section 106
units which we risk losing if we did not
expand our model to include them
I believe our members briefing on the
strategy listed both our previous and
our currently planned developments if
you'd like to look at the breakdown of
the sites that we've produced
it's very important to emphasize that
these are entirely additional units
as Mr Porter said we are not in
competition with housing associations we
do not want to be in any way and we're
simply determined to ensure that any
affordable housing created within the
planning system doesn't disappear and is
used to health our residents
if housing associations are interested
in different models of delivery and are
moving away from the delivery of smaller
numbers of units it's important to adapt
and include these properties to maximize
the delivery of genuinely affordable
housing in thanet
identifying this need and working to
include it within our strategy is
essential because the growth of our
housing portfolio directly enables
further growth via rent revenue and even
better provision for residents
this strategy begins with the delivery
of these 42 Homes at Spitfire green
it's well known by now that direct
funding to councils to enable social and
genuinely affordable housing does not
cover all costs related to the
development
as my supporters said our plans are
based on 60 of the cost of delivering
this program being funded by borrowing
within our housing revenue account with
the remaining 40 coming from external
funding such as affordable housing
grants from homes England section 106
planning agreements all the receipts
from right to buy sales
this is an approach that builds upon
itself a way to make housing actively
work to deliver further housing to make
genuinely affordable rent a reality in
thanet
purchases outlined here and planned for
the future makes housing work to produce
a genuinely sustainable and entirely
necessary step to guarantee the security
of our residents
I fully believe that investment in
housing is an investment in the future
of our residents and in our future as a
council
as such I'm utterly delighted to see
this item here and as always thank
housing and finance hugely for the work
that's gone into this project and I'm
happy to answer any questions alongside
the excellent Mr Porter thank you
thank you councilor Whitehead
so do members have any questions or
comments they would like to make our
hands up everywhere councilor cup
I was expecting to be picked first thank
you I know it did
um thank you councilor Whitehead
um as you have rightly said this is a
very important uh subject and the
incredibly important topic for the whole
of the district
um and the delivery of this is
incredibly important a couple of things
that I just wanted to ask was on of
those families that are on the
um housing waiting list
how many of those are families because
um from reading the the breakdown of
what this is actually purchasing nearly
80 yeah nearly 80 of the properties are
one bed Flats
um which obviously won't cater for
families so actually how much of an
indent will this take into the the those
families that are on the waiting list
because
um I could be able to say they are
sometimes our biggest priority to make
sure they're re-homed thank you chair
thank you um I'm happy to answer this
from my perspective and then get great
ideas from this supporter and we have a
huge demand for one bedroom properties
um so that's our principal need in terms
for providing for those who are on the
list so we do prioritize the one bed so
that we can ensure that
we're catering for the majority of those
that are lacking in that area
um one beds are particularly in demand
but we also produce family units
alongside that so we always try and look
at the proportions of what we're
providing and to ensure that they
reflect the list that we've actually got
so I hope that's okay from my
perspective but
I'm not shocking that much to that to be
honest I I mean just on the numbers that
um the single people are they're
actually the largest single group on the
housing register and more than half of
the households in temporary
accommodation are single people so there
is a clear need for one bedroom Flats
um I mean this happens that this is the
first project we brought along but if
across that the entire program that we
would there will be a balance of
different sizes
[Music]
Council Davis thank you
um again yeah very welcome these numbers
I'd just like to say it's and it's not
it's not this Project's fault it's a
shame you know it doesn't always send
the best message that we've just bought
42 houses on uh arable Farmland that
could have been producing but what I'd
like to ask is just to confirm the
policy of this Authority though is to
prioritize Brownfield development and
and infield infield in town stuff and so
on over yeah as I say I know it's not
this for this Project's fault or
anything it's just a shame that it the
message it sends you know
talk about this for hours but that would
bore everybody senseless and
it's always been our priority to build
on Brownfield and a lot of our
developments are effectively in fill
between current developments
the situation with agricultural land
to a large degree comes down to Central
policy
I do fight that on a national level but
in terms of what we're faced with
when we have developments that produce
affordable housing
to my mind a lot of the time that's
often the useful thing to come out of it
the only useful thing sometimes so we
are left with the situation of
using those because what we actually
need is genuinely affordable housing or
losing them completely in which case we
have a development that doesn't
provide for any of the residents on our
list
I don't agree with a lot of the central
planning policies and do talk about that
length
but we are working within the
limitations of the system that we're
faced with
um
and I think we're doing the best that we
can to provide for residents within that
thank you
councilwin
thank you and it's it's fabulous news
it's a shame it's only 42 but baby steps
you can only you can only buy what you
can afford and I know you're absolutely
passionate about uh people with
additional needs so I I'd just like to
ask will any of the properties Bill be
at disability or age proofed and I agree
that our biggest uh section of people
looking for housing is are single people
and it's not just young single people
it's it's older and elderly single
people so it would be quite nice to know
that some of the properties will be age
proofed on or adapted from ability have
we also got an opportunity if the next
phase of green grants come through to
help maybe put solar panels on these
buildings to actually remove or reduce
exorbitant energy bills because having a
roof over your house is obviously the
number one priority and then being able
to stay in there because you can pay
your bills and energy bills are massive
and I think I think uh Mr Porter said
that this 42 will be taken from the
developers allocation of social housing
the other thing will they all be in one
place or will these properties be
scattered so will we have a an area of
social housing within a private
development and hopefully shared
facilities in terms of playgrounds uh
but it's it's fabulous news so we're
well done everybody involved but
um again it kind of covers all three of
our areas here so I'll start
um in terms of disability accessible
properties
um we try to build with a home for Life
approach so in relation to what we do
we try and ensure that the homes that
we're building can be easily adapted so
that if residents do develop needs then
those homes can be easily adapted and
changed so that you don't have the life
disruption relating to that
in relation to how we are or the units
that we're looking at currently I think
we saw two of the disability
um
full access units when we did the site
visit last week yep
um so yes on that front we are ensuring
that we get the right mix of accessible
units and we're also promoting the home
for Life approach across all building
because
it just makes sense
um obviously we've got
adaptations funds that can work to help
within the private sector and also
within our own housing
but when you're choosing to build
literally from the ground up ensuring
that a property remains accessible and
is accessible is just the logical thing
to do and Energy Efficiency wise again
in terms of our own developments that is
something that we prioritize so if I
think back to King Street
we specifically included underfloor
heating so that you've got a
preventative measure there in terms of
heating the entire building and we do
incorporate as many measures as we can
it's slightly different within the
private Market because developers can
choose what they adopt as energy saving
measures but again
the approach that we take and
the priorities that we have
again will be reflected in the projects
that we choose to look at so I'm hoping
that this is part of a system-wide
change in that sense I have now
forgotten what the final question was
you've answered everything and the last
one would be probably to Mr Porter the
right to buy how many houses do we lose
annually maybe through right to bar so
is there a net loss
we're projecting less this year than
last year obviously the environment for
home buyers is quite difficult and
challenging at the moment so we are
projecting the rights by numbers to fall
um government have just recently uh
relaxed
um some of the restrictions on right to
buy receipts so previously a proportion
of the right rights by seats was taken
by central government and at least for
this year and next year uh government
are allowing councils to retain that and
put that money into their new build
program
um
in terms of numbers I think with we're
talking at the moment I think we're
projecting three for this year and I
think last year it was something like 15
or something like that I could get the
exact numbers for you I suppose my
concern was a net loss so yeah we bring
on 42 but we've sold 67 so no no no no
the sale numbers are much lower than
that I think there's two key things to
say about the right to buy though
firstly is the whole business plan works
on rent income
um not Capital values so Capital values
kind of irrelevant what's important is
how much rent we generate from those
homes because it's the rent that funds
all of the services we're providing and
it's the rent that funds are borrowing
for this program
so right to buy sale takes rent out of
the plan
um
The Good the the one pos one of the
positive things about the right to buy
regulations though is a thing called the
cost floor if you've not heard that it
gives us some protection and it means
that the sale value of any of our
properties can't fall below what we've
spent on it in the preceding period
which I think is 10 years but it might
be 15 I'm not certain but it's either 10
or 15 years so if we've so if it's a new
dwelling
um then the right to buy sale value
after discount can't fall below what
we've paid for it
Council of working
thank you and this is amazing news and
thank you and your passion for the
project for earlier shows um I just
wanted to talk about what we're
considering affordable just um I just
wanted some reassurance that given the
cost of living crisis and the way that
inflation is happening that we I
appreciate it may not help with our
deficit year on year but are we willing
to readjust what we consider affordable
year on year for the people who'll take
up these houses and also are we thinking
about affordability a little bit more
holistically not just in terms of energy
as we've talked about in terms of
insulation and to try and keep those
goals down and also in terms of things
like access to broadband to avoid the
digital divide and those sorts of
infrastructures being put in place for
the people who'll take on these homes
thank you
uh thank you I'm happy to go again
um
so
in relation to
affordable rent it's why you might
notice I tend to refer a lot to
genuinely affordable rent because
I don't believe that the central
government definition of affordable rent
is actually affordable
um our rents are either at or below
local housing allowance rates which
means that if you are relying on
benefits then your rent will be covered
by the local housing allowance which at
the moment is extraordinarily low
unfortunately
um so these are in every sense genuinely
affordable
um I'm happy to pass over to Mr Porter
for exact rates on that front I know
that oh three beds are slightly below
currently
um yeah I can't tell you the exact race
off the top of my head that was a
challenge wasn't it but they are on our
website so
um yeah the local housing allowance
rates for one two three and four bedroom
units are are on the council's website
so
um if you can't find it I'm more than
happy to send you the link
um just on on on Wi-Fi
um so the items would be fiber connected
um
obviously the resident will need to pay
their data costs but they will be
connected to you
um on the insulation front also I'd like
to refer back to the King Street
development because we had paper
insulation within that so it was both
ecologically sound but also very
important in terms of Energy Efficiency
so thank you
councilor point
I think I'm just going to Echo what
everyone said about this being brilliant
and I was very proud to support it last
week
um Council faruki just asked one of my
two questions around affordability so
thank you for that
um I'm really encouraged to hear that
answer
um
I'm not sure if you're going to be able
to answer my second question because
it's a bit kind of nebulous but
obviously any
any of this building and any additional
uh supply of housing for those in need
um eats into that 1604
um people in in need or in temporary
accommodation which is is brilliant
um and you've you've costed it up
brilliantly with the direct costs over
the years but obviously people in
need have indirect costs so there are
indirect costs on the NHS because people
have mental health issues there are
economic costs of lower educational
outcomes have we done any kind of
broader study as to the the indirect
costs of unaffordable housing
on on the NHS on mental health and on
educational outcomes in fanet
so in terms of health and education
outcomes that would usually fall under
KCC who I know have looked into that in
various ways
um
in terms of housing I think a good
demonstration of that would be the cost
of temporary accommodation
as compared to the cost of what we're
trying to do now in that
through not being able to House people
within our portfolio
we are accumulating extraordinary costs
so I think it was 2.2 million last year
in relation to paying for temporary
accommodation that is often out of area
when that is funding
that
could effectively be going back into
our housing
it's one of those very difficult areas
to juggle because it comes from
different funds not to get too weird
about it but
looking at things in a holistic Manner
and looking at the impact that no
housing or poor housing has on people is
a crucial part of this discussion
I say a lot that if we get housing right
everything else tends to fall into place
because I strongly believe that it does
both in terms of health outcomes and
educational outcomes and general quality
of life for residents
and it's to me very important to break
this cycle of having to respond to an
urgent situation such as eviction
therefore temporary housing out of area
which isn't suitable and then we're
losing families connections losing jobs
losing education
and instead try and move to a model that
sustains itself and allows us
to keep residents here and to give them
a lifestyle that is sustainable long
term there are
interim methods that we can do that so
looking to expand our in-house temporary
housing provision that we've started
with Foy house
because then when we do have these
emergency situations there is a way to
manage it but the long-term strategy has
to be
to provide for genuinely affordable
accommodation
um it reduces displacement it hopefully
prevents displacement and it improves
outcomes across all fronts so yeah I'm
extraordinarily passionate about it
because I think so many of the issues
our residents face can be solved
by taking this approach thank you I
think we can tell thank you
councilor Patman
yeah thank you for that um
just a quick one really about long-term
tenancy management of these residents
moving into these properties because
some of these uh residents or tenants
won't have managed a tenancy maybe
before or had to pay rent on time before
or manage bills is there a holistic
approach here from the council around
tenancy management
um we have an extraordinary team on that
front
um
and I think that's evidenced by the fact
that even in spite of the current
Financial conditions our entires fell
last year because we've got teams who
are actively supporting residents to
help them maintain tenancies and to help
them when they are struggling in terms
of rental costs
for those residents who are a bit more
vulnerable and maybe haven't maintained
a tendency before or who are coming from
a long-term background of homelessness
that's where the rise team are brilliant
because they can provide that level of
intervention and support and modeling
for how to maintain a tenancy and
provide ongoing support for those who
might just need a little bit more but
yeah we've got very committed teams who
do exactly that thank you
any more questions or comments to
members statistics I had a quick call
sorry just on to that last question
um we do routinely bring
um a performance report from the tenant
leaseholder Services here on its way to
um on its way to Cabinet
um and um the head of tennis and
leaseholder services Sally o'sullivanov
attends to present that
um and amongst other things it looks at
the work of the financial well-being
team that responsible for supporting
um
our tenants to access the incomes the
benefits there
um entitled to to help access any
support that's available for them and as
well as obviously collecting our own
rent income which is so important to the
business plan so there will be
periodically an opportunity to dig into
the detail of that here
okay members obviously this will now go
forward to coming is there any
recommendations we'd like to make or are
we happy with the report
we're all happy with the report
excellent so can we all please agree to
note the report
okay thank you okay moving on to item
number six also again about housing
local Authority housing the purchase of
nine homes again uh to present the
report uh Mr Porter
um yeah thank you I I'm not going to
repeat all the stuff I said in the last
report because this is broadly the same
principle
um so it's part of that program as well
um with the same principle that you know
60 ish of the cost comes from borrowing
any HRA and the remaining comes from
subsidy
um I think probably what is important to
say about this particular report is that
the subsidy in this case is coming from
central government from
um from D luck and it came in the form
of an allocated Grant we didn't actually
bid for it was allocated to the district
um 1.19 million and that Grant is to
support local councils to purchase homes
that will be used in the first instance
for families from Ukraine or Afghanistan
um and and for as long as that need is
required and then in the longer term
they form part of our normal housing
stock and we'll be let in line with the
council's allocations policy
I think the other thing to say about
this particular scheme in contrast to
Spitfire green is that um with Spitfire
green where there's a year one deficit
in the cash flow with this scheme there
is no deficit in year one for cash flow
the cash flow is in Surplus right from
the staff
so
oddly doing this enables us to do even
more of these projects subsequently and
so I think that's all I wanted to say by
introduction
um yeah happy to come in
um yes I'm very glad to express my full
support for the usage of the local
Authority housing fund within our larger
program of genuinely affordable housing
production
the resettlement of refugees from both
Ukraine and Afghanistan has in many ways
lacked the central Focus that good
support required
funding needed to have been given to
councils with statutory housing
obligations to provide for refugees in a
way that could provide reliable housing
and support those who have experienced
war and disruption often especially in
the case of resettlement schemes linked
to Afghanistan Those Who provided
support to British forces and need our
support now
there's lack of a foundational approach
has proved difficult for many councils
to manage as it's often resulted in
complex homelessness cases and the use
of accommodation that I would consider
to be unsuitable to provide for
individuals and families whilst they're
under the care of the home office
fund goes some way towards remeding this
the local Authority housing support fund
has been created to enable local
authorities to purchase properties in
their area to accommodate both Ukrainian
and Afghan Refugee households for an
initial period of three years
as a council we do our best to house
those who are most vulnerable
and we do well into start discharging
that Duty and will continue to do so
we have
3470 properties within our housing
portfolio all General needs housing all
used by residents who have been on our
housing list
what is proposed here relating to the
very specific requirements of a
particular governmental fund is the
purchase of nine homes or roughly 0.25
of our overall housing portfolio all of
which will eventually become General
needs housing for the current usage of
refugees from both the Ukraine and
Afghanistan who have arrived here as
part of government-led schemes
to my mind there are two main issues to
consider in relation to this item and
they're both interlinked
as human beings and as a council we have
a moral duty to do our best to support
those in need and those who are
vulnerable
this Grant and partial though it is
supports us to fulfill that Duty and to
provide for individuals who are
protected within our equalities act
commitments
secondly the fund also supports the
growth of our housing portfolio in
general which allows us to support all
residents in the long term
due to the grant as Mr Porter said these
homes will already be helping to support
the purchase and creation of new homes
from the point of purchase via rent
contributions
as we've discussed I'm especially aware
of the issues surrounding rent inflation
and planet and the need for social
housing as evidenced over many years of
council debates now and our ongoing and
future build and acquisition plans
reflect this General need
our ambitious social and affordable rent
program aiming to deliver over 400
affordable homes in the next four years
previously discussed tonight to reflects
this
however provision for one in this case
is provision for all and is a
significant contribution to our housing
infrastructure and it is important to
consider the full scope of both the fund
and our contribution to it in both a
moral and a financial sense
I would like to thank housing
wholeheartedly for all their work
relating to this project and as before
I'm happy to answer any questions
alongside Mr Porter
okay members if you've got any comments
or questions counselor what
hello again
um
again I'm really supportive of of this
and I I have
um I have two questions really
um the first is around the families
themselves
um obviously
these are these are people from
Afghanistan and Ukraine they've been
through an incredibly traumatic sort of
last two or three years
um and the adults and the children alike
uh that that come to these houses and
that take up residency those houses are
going to have had some some incredibly
awful experiences that I'm you know I
hope none of us ever have to go through
ourselves
um are we supplying support to them in
terms of uh
mental health support and just all
General kind of uh helping help to get
them up and running again sort of
spiritually as well as as well as sort
of you know giving them a house do we
give them the support they need that'd
be my first question my second question
would would be about their status as
well
um you know people that come
particularly you know I work with people
from Eastern Europe and you know they're
so much like us it's incredible
incredible and they want to work and
they are professional people
um are they able to work
um or are they in a kind of uh what what
status do they have in terms of being
able to make a contribution that I know
they would want to
I'll come in with what I notice if that
makes sense and
um obviously it's fairly furthest level
answer
um in relation to me but
relating to Health and Social care again
um there are particular funds within
Kent County Council that help to provide
support on that level
um so that would cross more into that
particular area
um
relating to status as these individuals
have come through resettlement schemes
to my knowledge there's no restriction
in relating relating to work so this is
very much
a community-based approach
um in terms of the details of how we're
identifying individuals and any support
that we can offer I'd like to pass over
to Mr Porter and
um
yeah so
um there is quite a lot of money for
support services so
um with together with the county we've
worked with the
um
we've worked with the southeast Council
for migration and with migrant helpline
and some of those support services are
commissioned directly by the county
including welcoming people when they
first arrive
providing
financial support and support with you
know setting up their home support with
any training education needs they may
have
um absolutely yeah it comes with the
right to work obviously that once the
home office has determined their
application they would have the right to
work in the in the economy so
um
in in terms of identifying people that
uh there are a number of different
routes that people can
um use so in terms of Ukraine there were
the two primary routes the um homes for
Ukraine which
you probably all remember the government
called out for people to offer up spare
rooms in their home and sponsor a
Ukrainian Refugee
um so that was one route into the
country and the other one was the
Ukrainian families scheme
um where um Ukrainian Nationals needed
to have a member of their extended
family already living in the area and
effectively saying they could go and
stay with them in either of those we've
got people in both of those sets of
circumstances in the district that are
either living with thanet-based families
that offered a room up or had extended
family in the district and obviously
they would be if their housing in
housing difficulties they would be
eligible for these projects the Afghan
scheme was primarily around people that
had supported the British forces in
Afghanistan and had were offered the
opportunity to apply for the refugee
status in the UK so and again we've got
um some of those cases in in the
district that may may need support with
their housing or would be eligible for
these these homes
thank you
yeah it's Council Austin
thank you I just want to say before
there was any support when we very first
had uh had Ukrainian refugees coming
over we set up through uh Ramsgate Town
Council a support group which used to
meet now it doesn't because everybody's
working and whatever but there is a
WhatsApp group all in Ukrainian I get it
on my phone I don't understand a word of
it apart from when there's a poster of
something in English but there is if if
anybody comes across
um a Ukrainian individuals or families
who are lacking in information or links
with other Ukrainian people in fanet do
let us know because we can put them in
touch and it's a phenomenally useful
group they've managed to do so much
themselves to support each other it's
brilliant
that's really helpful um the that group
is actually organized by one of our own
employees
um who is a Ukrainian national herself
and we recruited her specifically as a
Ukrainian family support worker with
some of the money that came from KCC
um and um you know having having her and
the staff is really you know it's really
helpful because it can really
um build help us build some
relationships with those families and
support those families
we're delighted that you took her on and
she's she's been fabulous yeah
excellent councilor copy you next
uh thank you chair and once again this
is a really good scheme and I think that
this is really important that we're
supporting those
um in need my my concern is around and I
don't know councilor Whitehead if you've
you've received any emails from from
residents but often when unfortunately
something like this happens or is put
into the public Realm people turn around
and go oh well what about us you know
we're still in the housing nest and
everything like that and
um I think that it's important to ensure
that when press release is going out
there just obviously saying how
important it is that we are supporting
um these people because it absolutely is
but also that in actual fact by allowing
us to do this it is uh also ensuring
that we are putting Provisions in place
for our own housing stock as well and
supporting our own residents and
um I apologize it's not really much of a
question but more of a kind of a general
kind of ask I suppose but um when when
it comes to press releases and things
like that around this
um I think that we've just got to be
really robust in or ask you if we could
be really robust in being really clear
on what this policy is and actually try
and take away take it away from those
that are just going to put on the
rhetoric that are what about us because
I think you know Unfortunately they
don't understand the policy in this form
lengths and I think it's really
important that we as a council main
robust on why we're committed to this
kind of policy thank you chair
thank you
there's quite a few factors relating to
this in
to my mind this is part of our overall
strategy in terms of delivering
genuinely affordable housing
um as I said before it's just over 0.25
of our housing stock which is a very
small amount and it's also working
towards delivering further housing
from the moment we purchase it
effectively
the conditions around this were very
much because the expression of Interest
went in quite a while ago under the
previous administration we
have to work the time frames given by
that fund so to ensure transparency
within the council we have to make sure
that things are published for the right
meetings in time for us to actually be
able to access the funds so that we can
support people
um
as I said as far as I'm concerned this
is part of us providing for all of our
community
and I do fully understand the stresses
that people are under and I receive many
many emails a day from residents who are
extraordinarily concerned about their
housing situation or in Desperate
situations often
but I try and think of it in terms
of what I would want and how I would
want
my son to be treated if we ended up in
the same circumstances I would want to
believe that other countries would
welcome him I would want to believe that
there would be a home for us
and
I think people understanding the human
aspect of this is really important
because
people can choose to report on things in
any way they wish to and unfortunately
negative reports often move faster than
positive
but we all have a choice in how we
interpret them and we can choose to look
at another person in need and recognize
that need and recognize our mutual
Humanity
or we can choose to look at it in terms
of
they have something that I want or they
have something that I don't have
to my mind
what these individuals have is
experience of a trauma that I don't want
to imagine
um
and the least we can do is to try and
support them to settle in a place
where I hope they will be safe and where
I hope they will be careful by all of
our community
thank you
yeah thank you I think we all share that
sentiment who else indicated Council
Davis
yeah again I'd like to uh Echo how
welcome this scheme is and how important
it is obviously there's some there's a
just one issue I'd like some
clarification on is why it has quote an
initial period of three years these
people are in need of housing are they
not being given the same permanent
facility and security as a normal
tenancy what happens in three years
you're surely not suggesting that we say
to them okay off you go
the vulnerability particularly with the
Afghans is is still going to be here
isn't it so so isn't it a little bit
disingenuous to say oh yeah but it will
come into the housing stock it is either
in the housing stock from day one or it
isn't
so the wording there comes from the
actual funds which is a bit depressing
to be honest
um so it's worded that way simply
because that's how the fund is raised
we wouldn't want anyone to feel that
they have a secondary tendency
yes
I'm happy to pass over to Mr Porter but
we wouldn't want anyone to feel that
they weren't yeah
yeah it's the fund thank you
yeah yeah
um I went seven or seven hours about
this actually there was a lot of
questions from a lot of councils about
the duration and the tenancies and
frankly government didn't know the
answer to any of those questions
um we've got
um we've got tenancy's policy that only
provides for two types of tenancies
um so one is a a license for people that
we've got statutory homeless homeless
duty to whilst they're in temporary
accommodation and waiting for permanent
home and the other one is a lifetime
secure tenancy so depending on the way
that the family
apply it will be either one of those
awesome
so either could apply in this instance
then it could be that they're on a
license so they are in effect temporary
okay no thank you it'll be one of those
because they're the only two sorts of
tenancy that we offer well smashing
thank you thanks for clearing that
anybody oh cancel the win
because obviously we worked quite
closely with the with the ukrainians but
I I mean I welcome this but it's just a
sad fact that this country chooses to
deal with migrants in two very distinct
ways and I'd call them a system of
apartheid if you like some people get
some people are treated differently and
I think it's we mustn't forget that that
the reason we we we don't have a social
housing stock is because we've been
starved of funding for too many years
and we have a present political system
that prefers to spend money housing
people in boats offshore rather than
investing people so I I thank you for
this but I think it's just a shame that
that our the immigrants are treated in
so starkly different ways which is out
of our control but I do work on the fact
we are at least trying to do the decent
thing to support uh two groups of
vulnerable people
yeah I
I know I speak about it a lot but
the way that things are funded or not
funded in the case of housing frequently
um
means that the provision
that's been offered has often been very
piecemeal
um so
in taking up this fund it feels like
again a more foundational approach to
actually providing it feels as if it's
something that
can actually create Home and Community
rather than it being
we will simply find a way to accommodate
it's something
that I struggle with personally because
the lack of stock
means that we can't provide in the way
that other countries do because we don't
simply don't have the stock to Simply go
this is how we're going to deal with it
but
I hope that this brings us a step closer
to
providing the community and home that
people need
okay
okay so I think we'll wrap it up there
so again this report has to go to
Cabinet next week so there's any
recommendations that we want to make
we're all happy with the report we're
all happy to note the report
okay thank you okay so moving on I'm a
bit conscious of time and that officers
are giving up their evening to be with
us this evening so I'm going to move
item number nine forward and so item
number nine leveling up fund and the
Margate Town deal projects update so no
members are I remember from the work
program when we talked about
um
subjects to scrutinize and a lot of it
became
around the leveling up fund so we've
asked the officers to come and give us a
full update on all the projects that are
going on internet so I'll call on let's
ask you to bring the report
evening thank you thank you for your
invite
um so I think the request was to
particularly pick up projects within the
town deal and leveling up fund programs
by a way of an update so
um I wanted to start by just sharing a
slide and we've shared this often with
staff and in our members briefings which
highlights some of the funding that's
been awarded and allocated over the last
few years in terms of our regeneration
program and I've highlighted Margate
Town doing Ramsgate leveling up fund
more for the newer members so that they
can see how much funding has been
allocated to those programs and they
were the two that I was going to focus
on particularly this evening
within those two programs there's about
20 individual projects this is quite a
lot I probably would some might have
more detail in terms of my update
um just because there's a lot to get
through uh just for a bit of context
um within the team that overlooks looks
after Ramsgate projects we have a
project manager a project assistant
manager and an apprentice project
assistant manager and then in Margate we
specifically have a one project manager
and then we have two uh as sorry as a
general regeneration project manager and
then we have two specific project
officers working one on the theater
Royal and one on our Coastal well-being
activities for the town deals so we're a
really small team and this is some of
the funding that we've been working
within most recently so leveling up and
town deal were quite two quite different
processes
um
the town deal was an allocation we were
one of 101 places to put together an
investment plan uh the leveling up funds
was a competitive bidding process that
we were successfully awarded the 19.8
million four they have different
processes in terms of management and
Reporting
um but all up to central government
so how do we share updates I think that
was one of the
um uh requests as part of attending this
meeting was to help members feel up to
date and have more information about the
projects so we've got our Council web
pages
um I think we nearly broke our website
because we were given campaign pages to
put town do on leveling up information
on and
um we've had to redo those and move them
into the main content of our website so
that we make sure we can keep adding the
information on there
um so we've done a recent update
following the uh event
um this week on the Ramsgate project and
we are busy working on updates for the
Margate Town deal
we have our wave newsletter we have the
loop which is for our members we
um Colin Carmichael does a fortnightly
update to members and we use that to
provide information
um to all members we have press releases
to our Media Partners and we respond to
press inquiries we have regular members
updates so we more recently provided an
update for members on the UK share
Prosperity fund
prior to the election we did uh I think
we did a ramsgator Margate and a
Ramsgate so we're quite often uh you'll
quite often see my face at a members
update
um we have stakeholder lists and groups
and um as those all attended that
attended Ramsgate uh this week we'll
have seen we've started to try and do a
bit more
um engagement activity through events
I saw some pictures of
um of the event and we felt that it was
important that we were actually in the
in the center of the harbor and and you
may see some of yourselves there we were
really pleased to have seen so many
members
come along and look at the information
that we were providing and ask questions
of our project management and design
teams on the day
so this is a slide we've used a lot I
know it's quite a busy one but it is uh
this information is on our website but
essentially it shows the three different
uh key interventions around the port of
Ramsgate
um one around Greenport and that's
predominantly about that bigger growth
in Economic Opportunity one around our
inclusive Harbor so that's how can we
make better use of some of the assets we
have in and around the harbor and then
the last one is around assets within our
community that we can help
um to to build on to encourage some of
our communities to engage more in these
regeneration programs
um
the basis of the leveling up fund and
and the Margate Town deal is about job
creation growth and providing
opportunities for young people we know
that in Ramsgate there was no job growth
in 10 years and we that can't happen
um so that was the driving force behind
many of these
so if you were at the me if you were at
the event on Thursday you will have seen
some of these images and I uh I
understand that the uh artist's
impression of the cargo ship in the
middle of the port provided
um quite a lot of debate it it's just an
image
um and is definitely not to scale so it
wouldn't be in our in our Port but this
just shows you some of the work that
we're doing with border force and I
appreciate It's tricky to see probably
with the lights on here but this is on
our website so it's easy for you to have
a look at but this shows the work that
we're doing with border Force so we've
got a design team on board they're
working directly with board forces as a
stakeholder to make sure that we have
the right
um
uh the right things on the ground in
terms of what they need and then we're
working separately around the
specification for The Mooring spine and
the birth
um to make sure that they are suitable
and fit for purpose as part of the
debate that we've already heard this
evening
um
so this uh forms this is a an image of
the green Campus we have yankitain
Architects on board
um they are currently at Reba stage one
um this has a great opportunity for
growth it's the modular building we're
working with stakeholders be it
education providers organizations
working within the hydrogen industry and
also our customers at the Port of
Ramsgate including offshore Wind Farm
operators and others that we know have
training and skills requirements in the
maritime industry we quite often talk
about the kind of decarbonization of the
sector and thinking more broadly what
things we can learn from other places
and the team are visiting a block site
tomorrow
and you know we've been talking to lots
of different organizations about how
they've worked we've also visited Austin
who has a similar sort of complex albeit
there's this university-led
but we have a broad stakeholder group
involved in this and we're trying to
create a space that allows
um organizations to grow and engage with
the sector as well
uh and the there are some further plans
that look at how if funding and or
investment comes forward this could grow
within the space around it
uh this is just a drawing of the fishing
facility there was some further this and
this is again on our website we
um at a previous members briefing I
think we talked about an application
that we submitted to
um the seafood infrastructure fund which
was unfortunately unsuccessful that
would have given us greater scope and
opportunity for this site we understand
that the fishermen could make greater
value from their catch if it can be
processed on on site rather than it
traveling to somewhere else before it
ends up on a plate and therefore
reducing its miles one of the things
that we've been working with the thanet
fisherman's Association is thinking
about how we can improve that
opportunity for
um
the boats within our Harbor to support
those fishermen to be able to recruit
and grow the sector it's been
challenging
um I think with all of the programs any
capital investment whether it be across
housing
leveling up town deal future High Street
fund we are being faced with
unprecedented inflationary costs and I
think that was mentioned earlier
um we are also impacted from being
around one bid on the increase in
labor costs and material costs due to
the challenges we've been facing from
leaving the EU and the war in the
Ukraine so it's had a massive impact and
we are working with our broad project
management team Acom who we've brought
on to support the team and our cost
Consultants to really evidence that and
Lobby
um central government and I I think
councilman has talked about have are we
speaking to central government and the
Secretary of State and that is something
that we are doing because there are
absolutely challenges and we do not want
to temper our ambition around delivery
um because of those and we are looking
at every opportunity either four other
sources of funding or
other sources of funding or how we can
value engineer the
um delivery to reduce it down but with
the potential for further growth uh or
making sites bigger should uh funding
come forward so we've got a design team
called Pascal and Watson working with us
on this and
we have looked to move the site
um in the harbor to make it more
suitable for the fishermen on the basis
that we didn't get that broader
um
funding that we had applied for
so I'm going to move on to the clock
house and Pier yard
the architect team working with us are I
know it's really tricky to see on here
but as I said again this is on our
website
um
we are looking at extending
um on the ground floor and out to create
a food and beverage offer that will help
support and sustain the um
operation within the museum we are
working with the Ramsgate society and
other key stakeholders in developing a
plan for the future to ensure that it is
a sustainable operation and we have a
successful expression of Interest
through the national lottery Heritage
fund and we are applying for a
development Grant in the August deadline
so National Lottery
Heritage fund is a two-stage process you
submit a development Grant and then you
submit a full Grant nine to 12 months
later and one of the opportunities that
we have is the funding within
um
the LA leveling up fund to provide match
funding
um
and we've been working very closely with
historic England and our internal
conservation
officer to make sure that what we
deliver is in keeping with the building
and the site for those that don't know
the Royal Harbor has now got a an
overall listing of being grade two star
listed it had three or four different
individual sites around the harbor were
listed but there were bits missing in
between the whole of the the harbor Is
So that obviously has an impact in the
way that we develop our schemes and put
proposals forward
and this also links in with the
opportunity around Pier yard and we are
scoping how that would work as a public
space being mindful that we require
access
um into the for the fishing fleet and
also
um up to the brasserie and we've been
working with
um Kent County Council highways to think
about whether there's an opportunity to
move the road and access for the um
for the brasserie at the end of the pier
as part of that development
um with uh as I said in terms of the
inflationary pressures the challenge
that provides for listed listed
buildings is huge with new builds you
can value engineer it by making it
smaller
um with listed structures that's really
difficult to do you cannot compromise on
the materials or the quality of design
because because it's you know we can't
do that to our heritage assets so it is
proving to be a challenge
um for these although we are benefiting
from the fact that the clock house is
applying for National Lottery Heritage
fund
um the smack boys uh which The Proposal
is for a restaurant with rooms because
apparently boutique hotels are out
we have had a number of conversations
with independent operators because it's
a relatively small site and would and be
more appealing to the independence than
chains and the challenge in terms of the
funding Gap is not insignificant in
terms of that development so we're doing
quite a lot of work at the moment
working with our Architects to see what
the the kind of art of the possible is
within that building because we don't
want to lose the opportunity that we've
got with the leveling up fund so that
one is going to be a slightly trickier
um proposal bringing forward
um particularly because of the
inflationary pressure and which is
partly why we we are trying to engage
with the secretary of state and the
department
um so we've got two access to
opportunity schemes
um as I said these are about providing
uh sorry I should go back and say the
leveling up fund is all capital
investment it's about buildings it's
about land there isn't any Revenue
funding allocated with this program
that's the way it was set out by central
government so this is about creating
buildings where
um
we can deliver programs of activity and
we are
um you we are looking to the UK share
Prosperity fund to help us deliver some
of that
um and this is the future High Street
fund scheme and as part of that we uh in
um sorry being delivered in Broad Street
um as part of that we're delivering the
Town Center access to Opportunities site
and then as the leader mentioned this is
the Newington
Community Center and I think one that
the team are actually really excited
about delivering because we can see very
very quickly
um the communities and the organization
and being able to take advantage of this
and link up with the um
link up with the jobs that we are
planning on creating through the kind of
food and beverage opportunities so it's
it's a development of a kitchen but we
are looking at the green spaces around
and trying to improve the building
um
we are working with architects yankitain
who are um particularly good at looking
at spaces in a creative and engaging way
um so we're quite excited about that
opportunity so they they're all the
right and this is a real Whistle Stop
um through these so this slide is
another one that kind of showcases the
Margate Town deal I appreciate it is
very busy
um we have a number of key interventions
across the 22.2 million
um
scaling margate's creative production
and skills one of the things that we
know is the SEC the the creative sector
is growing but it is incredibly
challenged by land and buildings and we
have seen some very good organizations
really struggle with private landlords
so
um we through the plan sorry through the
tan investment plan we have set up a
creative land trust it is an independent
organization has a number of Trustees
they have recruited an executive
director and a community engagement and
Communications manager to and they've
both recently started their
um
uh the trust have put together a
property subgroup and are working
through a long list of potential sites
and assets and putting that through a
kind of criteria for investment they've
also been working with
um the creative sector to understand
what the need is what kind of spaces
they need and it's about safeguarding
and holding properties in perpetuity but
also by supporting the sector more
broadly by providing advice and and
guidance from the the capacity that they
gain with delivering it themselves
um as part of this uh sorry I'm gonna
have a drink
and part of this intervention includes
the theater Royal it is a an asset that
the council owns and we have as part of
that
employed a specialist project manager
who will be putting together or who is
working on an updated vision and she's
putting together a national lottery
Heritage fund expression of interest and
we are hoping to submit a development
Grant application in the new year I
think I read somewhere somebody said why
couldn't we just submit it tomorrow and
if only we could we're working really
hard with a number of organizations
across than it to make sure that we
don't put one more than one than it bid
into a round because if we do then they
become in competition with each other
and there are only four application
dates across the year so we don't want
to be competing I don't want to have too
Theater Royal in a clock house project
competing with each other we want them
to stand out on their own so
um we're putting that together at the
moment
we have
um put a lot of done a lot of work
around surveys structural surveys we are
developing a vision and we are going to
complete some
urgent minor Works to the roof to help
Safeguard the interior of the building
one of the benefits that we have for the
theater Royal this time round where
we've tried before is two million pounds
and grant funding to actually act as
match which has always been a challenge
before and the project includes a
Theater Royal and 19 Hawley square and
the point about having 19 Hawley is to
provide some sustainability
um for the theater going moving forward
and we've recently had some theater's
trust funding just ten thousand pounds
but that's helping us test the business
case uh for the future of that
we also have a program of Outreach
education engagement and that's some of
the The Limited Revenue funding as part
of this again the majority of central
government funding that has come out has
been Capital which is great because than
it has
um has not benefited from kind of
regeneration Capital funding for a long
time because of the way programs were
directed
um but also the impact in cutting
funding to local authorities has mean
has meant that there are challenges
around Revenue funding but the Margate
Town Deal Board was particularly keen on
working out how both with
um
the creative Industries but also around
Coast Health and well-being
how we can engage with our communities
and make them part of this thinking
about how we can show people that jobs
within the creative industry are not
just for artists and what other
opportunities they are available and
it's not just for art galleries
um Coastal well-being oh I've started
talking and sorry I realize I've got
some images here
um Coastal well-being includes a number
of different projects around the kind of
Walpole Bay Area within cliftonville
West and so there are improvements we've
got match funding for improvements to
the tidal pool with the environment
agency and we're working with our
Technical Services team on that we are
developing a site to test uses one of
the proposals that came forward for the
town deal was to sort out the Lido site
and we were only allowed to bid for 25
million and I don't think we would have
enough to do that and the other things
in the town as part of that funding so
we are looking at a way of testing uses
around health and well-being and Coastal
activities to Showcase that the
businesses can develop and grow and
there might be further opportunities for
sites like the Lido in the future
um there are a number of sites across
the top of the uh at the front at
cliftonville's the oval bandstanding
Lawns refurbishment and the development
of a skate park next to the play parking
in cliftonville
um we are also improving access to the
bay through investment in the lift and
the stairs we know that there's a number
of
um
uh older people's homes in in that area
and they struggle to get down with the
lift not working so we are thinking
about how we draw together all of those
activities at Walpole Bay and we know
it's a busy you know it's a growing
Beach when I first started doing this
nobody went to Walpole Bay and and it
was fine that there were no facilities
there it's now not and we're pushing
forward on on that investment
um to help do that and we've got a
design team working with us to put that
together we have internal stakeholder
groups and uh and external
um
uh the one of the other interventions
was active movement and connections and
I don't have any pretty pictures to show
for that at the moment but the ambition
is around how do we move people more
easily between Margate and cliftonville
around our Coastline and through our
town centers and we've got some
wayfinding activity as part of that and
a toilet provision in Margate
um which we are talking about bringing
forward
um we recently met with the County
Council to talk about the highway scheme
uh we are definitely a lot Highway
experts but
um they are being really supportive in
in thinking about how we can propose
those schemes to the next stage where we
will have to do uh some significant
engagement because highways is always uh
controversial
um in terms of changes some people
like new schemes and others don't
uh the last intervention is
um diversifying Our Heritage assets so
we have two Investments one is for
Destination Dreamland which is mainly
focused at the um Cinema
um complex
um essentially it is an investment to
unlock further private investment which
was a significant requirement for Town
deal areas and
um it's about the unlocking that
Heritage deficit which is something
historic England talk a lot about and
and the challenge that we've always had
in coastal Resorts have is these big
Heritage assets
um are not fit for purpose in this
current time and and this uh four
million investment should help to unlock
that we're about to add some information
on to the website about the program with
an updated kind of tie timeline and we
are talking to um
Dreamland about their uh the grant
agreement and commissioning the
specifics around that and then
um the Winter Gardens so we had a
smaller amount of Revenue funding to
complete a number of surveys we've got
quite a lot of information online
already about the surveys structural
surveys building electrical mechanical
conditions legal reviews site surveys
asbestos drainage you name it we've done
them
we have an updated FAQ section on the
website because we know there's a lot of
love and interest for this building the
image on the right is and you can't see
it particularly well here but it forms
part of the evening and nighttime
economy review that we've done and the
specifics around the Winter Gardens
shows the different stages of different
parts of the Winter Gardens as they were
built
and it's fascinating when you pair it
back to think about what the original
building looked like and what the the
opportunities in scope might be
um for the future of that we've just
finished a commission to bring in
um a and a oh my goodness an agency to
support taking out a marketing agency to
support taking it out to the market and
testing what the opportunity and uses
might be
um with the with the broader private
sector
so I think yes that's my last slide
sorry I I know I talked really quickly
um but I wanted to try and get through
those this evening
thank you Miss Askew that's an excellent
presentation I think we all agree so
members
questions
oh hands up Council car are you at first
well thanks Louise for your presentation
I know it's uh big projects and you've
got a fairly small team uh as an awful
lot of work in in there what I'd like to
ask is um I know you're at a stage now
where you could give a presentation like
this and we can take this back to the
public there isn't a great deal to take
back to the public at the moment because
the projects are such an early stage but
what I would ask is when the time's
right would you uh arrange some
Community engagement meetings so we can
really bring the the public in and uh
and keep them updated on uh on on the
projects particularly the the coastal
well-being project but I think it's one
of those projects where Community
engagement is really important and we've
got a lot of people in the area that
would really like to to know exactly
maybe a rough timeline because there's a
lot of people think everything will be
built sort of next year when when in
effect there's um I think it's it's uh
2026 uh to for these projects to be
delivered thank you
thanks yes uh the team really want to do
some Community engagement activities the
one that we did at the um Turner
contemporary was really well received
and it was a very early stage as we had
just submitted or we were just
submitting the investment plan so
they're really Keen what we don't want
to do is turn up with nothing people
like as they did in Ramsgate like to be
able to see even to critique to say well
actually I think I you know it could
look a bit like this or we might want
something have you thought about doing
this and so it's really good to be able
to do that but we um we are really keen
and the project officer that's involved
in the coastal well-being activities is
out there talking to stakeholders all
the time putting people together
creating
um different opportunities so there is
definitely something that we can do more
of
um we're trying to put some timelines
together now to think about what are the
key next steps moving forward and that
and information will go online and and
as part of that there will be some more
engagement
I'd just like to say also thanks for
meeting with cliftonville West
councilors know if you've met other
councilors as well because that was
really useful thanks
Council Davis
um
yeah thank you for your presentation
Louise
um I'm going to try and sort of pray see
some questions here because obviously
again there's you know there's a lot of
different issues on the different
projects and so on
um You referred to him being at a very
early stage and I've noticed that in
some of the forward plan stuff for
instance with regard to um there's a
phrase about early engagement with the
green energy sector and the budget for
that isn't even until next year
which so I'd question the phrase earlier
early engagement I I A lot of people are
asking why we're still at this
incredibly early stage two years after
the grant was announced
um and it would be good to know why
because of a lot of people and I think
it's Justified would expect there to be
a lot more meat in these
another observation by the way is that
on the visuals that were used in the
public consultation the other day brex
has magically doubled in size
now there's delegated authority to the
chief executive to negotiate and explore
expansion of Brits but there's a lot of
issues that we have with lack of
enforcement on their environmental
breaches and so on and I think it's
predetermination and certainly
assumptive to show them as twice the
size on documents that are being
produced to the public
um particularly given that there's
argument about whether it's necessary or
not
um it's clearly an agenda there because
there's a video from 2016 talking about
Brett's expanding now it keeps being
denied and I think that's something that
again we'd like some clarity on
um but anyway sorry I'll come back
we're already engaging we
uh in particular we're working with the
10 District growth board and they've got
some specialists in that and thinking
about their support in unlocking
investment or engagement with other
organizations there's quite a lot
happening already
um
the yeah why why are we here we're two
years down the line um when we submitted
the bid we were two people in
regeneration and we have been growing
slowly
um alongside the development and
delivery of activities around the
Margate Town deal ideally we would be
further along but I think there was a
report in the national press that showed
five percent of um
love round one programs at only only
five percent have been delivering
because there's significant challenges
that I outlined around the cost
inflationary pressures and we are having
to revisit everything
um because of that so
um we've taught up as it were in terms
of the team we've got a really good
project management team in Acom working
us through to Reba stage three we've got
our design teams on board and um the uh
activity in in recent months has been
huge so um I expect to see a lot more
coming out in those in terms of the
images I guess you're talking about this
one
um Brett's hasn't doubled in size it's
this is the scope of Works in terms of
what border Force need and where this
forms not dissimilar to how the the
previous Ferry operator managed the
space so we know how it works it isn't
about anything has doubled in size is
just about this is where the operation
works the road this is where it works
for the road coming in from the
roundabout and for the flow of traffic
in and around the port so uh
is actually
that's the Border forced operations
yeah that's the Border Force operations
Council of Austin
thanks Louise and congratulations again
on a bringing in that massive amount of
money into the area and and also on the
event on Tuesday which I think was
really useful I wanted to ask about
um how how are you going to use the
feedback that you're getting from that
event and whether we can all as
counselors have a link to the survey so
that we can all share it please with our
residents for those who didn't manage to
get there
um I wanted to ask about
um the the road project
um in Ramsgate the
um the harbor parade and um the main
road bit and where we are with that
because obviously that underpins some of
the other
um stuff regarding the clock house and
the potential to pedestrianize or change
the the way that that all of that works
around
um around the harbor and then picking up
on councilor Curry's point and this is
probably less a point for you but more a
point for our future work program uh
Council mentioned timelines and I know
when I suggested that we need something
about our regeneration projects at every
meeting I wasn't suggesting that Louise
should turn up at every meeting and do a
presentation like this that would be
totally unreasonable what I was looking
at was we as looking at the the birth
four and five report has been mentioned
earlier in the in the evening and we've
looked at what lessons we've learned and
about that we need to be sure we have a
project management framework for
everything we do we need timelines we
need to look as a committee at are we
up to where we need to be with various
projects are we up to the spend that we
need to have made etc etc etc that
shouldn't need to involve Louise at
every meeting but it might need to
involve a project manager or an
individual or a consultant or whatever
but I do believe really strongly that
this committee's role is to scrutinize
that at every meeting so that we are on
top of it because this is a massive
amount of money coming into our district
we it has the potential to make a
transformative difference but we need to
be on top of the process not the not all
the content but but the process so that
that's that's not really a question to
Louise that's a comment with regard to
where this sits but I'd be interested in
knowing about the feedback and about the
roads please
Fab thank you so um we actually had
about 300 people through the doors on
Tuesday which is really good and the
team uh uh what yeah were really pleased
with that
um and all of the surveys went uh which
means people took them away and some
were returned on the day we will
absolutely share the link and we can do
that and I'll just check because what we
might want to do is put a deadline on
that so that we can then use it for the
next phase so
um different parts of the information
will be shared with the different design
teams and as a team we will have a look
at a kind of overall report to make sure
we're picking up and or using some of
the information to create some FAQs for
our website and anyone that links in
through the your voice than it can
register to say they'd like an update so
when we put those foqs online we can
then provide them that update directly
um the future High Street fund Road
um I think that's I need to check but I
think that's due to start in the Autumn
obviously we can't
do it in the summer and we can't do it
at Christmas and we can't do it when the
birds are nesting and the newts are
crossing the road so um we have really
tight time scales in terms of delivering
road infrastructure in particular so um
but I think it's due to start in the
Autumn yes
um and I did want to just come back on
your last Point
um one of the benefits of now having a
bigger team with lots and lots of
different skills is we are putting some
some more easy to use kind of timelines
and we have some very
um convoluted monitoring and evaluation
returns for central government and what
we're trying to do is create a more
simplified version within the council so
that we can all use that much more
easily so there's a lot of work going
behind the scenes on that as as well as
managing it
Okay so we've got Council greenext and
Council Wing then Council Patman
thank you Luis um
you mentioned the need to find an
operator for the
SPAC boys project
but it's also true that the the clock
house the Broad Street project
the Newington project
and also probably the fishing facility
are all going to need operators going
forward
which means they all need to be
sustainable
how much work have you done to and to
convince yourself
that they are all sustainable
uh thank you yes we um we are looking at
what the different operator models are
for each of them
um in terms of the um Broad Street in
the future High Street fund project that
has the access to opportunities that
formed part of the work we did
um to submit the bid for the future High
Street fund and we've commissioned a bit
more work around updating that to help
us understand there there is potential
for crossover for a number of them
particularly the workspaces so obviously
we own the Kent Innovation Center
um the the creative workspace in
Ramsgate and the green Campus have a
real Synergy around work and the
opportunity to do more around education
linking with those
um we've been working with the thanet
fisherman's Association around the
fishing facility and think and and there
is more work to be done around thinking
about how that would be run and we are
talking to our newly appointed head of
property to think more broadly are there
any other opportunities linked with
other sites that we've got but that
operator model is something that we are
working on at the moment and to bring in
some extra resource to make sure that
each of those within those designs and
so there's a
um
there's a kind of a joint relationship
between the two is does that design work
for the operation and that's a piece of
work we're doing at the moment
it's the win thank you um it's good to
thank you Louise because it's good to
see the whole projects in a sense and
how you know on Ramsgate based but it is
good to to get an idea or a sense of
what's Happening across our towns I go
to the or did go to the theater I also
you know we have some key things in both
towns that are vitally important to us I
too went to the the the love thing and
it was in Ramsgate it was really well
attended and I did know where the uh the
crane the crane the crane shed was uh
and it was good to hear that people are
thinking that the Sea Cadets might end
up in the green Hub because that is a
major concern that we talk about
opportunities for young people and then
we throw them out of the smack boys and
we don't find a home for them so I
welcome I welcome that we we found the
Sea Cadets at home and it is near the
sea also the High Street money in the
road uh councilor Austin asked that
question have we any idea of how that
will will relate to obviously access Us
in and around the harbor and the port
which is extremely difficult and we have
a number of near missiles when the
tunnel is shut and clearly the tunnel is
not can't be shut if we have all this
extra industry and and vehicles moving
in and out so that that is the
responsibility of KCC and I think
they've got to do what they do with the
Herm Bay uh bypass and do it at night or
put traffic lights in
I just I I when I when we talked about
this before I asked a question about how
is the funding and I specifically
mentioned the 500 000 to the oval
Bandstand the Newington and also the
four million that went to Dreamland
and the answer I got was retrospective
funding which I find really difficult I
manage the multi-million pound project
as a senior teacher in a school we were
we were especially sports college
delivering across a
metropolitan area a big a big
metropolitan area and I I led on that
and and my funding was received once our
application was successful a year in
advance so I got one year's funding
reported the end very tough government
reports to fill in have to be really
well evidenced if you don't achieve a
name you have to justify why you've not
achieved that aim it might go in a
different direction because these things
as they evolve we all go in different
directions but we couldn't have
delivered that project without having
that that funding and then delivering a
year reporting getting the next lot
so I was a bit concerned about that with
the retrospective funding because I
don't know how anybody can deliver
a project by finding the money
themselves and then claiming it back
once they've done that I'd also I mean
we do I'd really love if uh chair we
could bring in some of the people that
are running these projects that we've
granted
to to to to to experience an idea of not
just their successes but what their
barriers have been because there will be
a significant number of barriers what
you plan to do at the start of a project
is sometimes not what you plan to not
what you do at the end it might be
better it might be worse but it I would
really like to understand that human
experience and I was quite concerned
that the oval Bandstand seemed to be
seemed to be pulling back from TDC and I
hope that we're making every effort I I
I I I I started taking an interest in
Margate because I I felt it was always
them and us and so I felt I needed to
address my preconceptions about Ramsgate
being the best place in thanet and and
go and visit Margate and so I got a bit
much better understanding of why each of
the towns are so special uh and it seems
to me that that oval Bandstand and the
skate park is is in such a prime
location to actually be a really
successful projects particularly the
over band stand there isn't a cafe well
there is a Palm Bay Cafe but it's not
open you've got to get a takeaway and
you know you follow some of the things
that are happening and the oval Band
Stand seems to be delivering things that
that local people are attending and want
so it's already successful so I guess
that's what my concern is can we have an
idea of what money we've spent what's it
been spent on and how successful it's
been in part of these this summing up
and I would also really like to speak to
some of the people delivering the
projects to see what their successes are
and what their barriers have been
so I'm not sure if there was a question
there but
I think there was about the funding I
find that difficult the the the the the
the uh retrospective funding I don't I
have no idea how that can work
thank you oh no I was going to come back
on that and say yeah we can look at
inviting maybe some from the Margate
Town Deal Board or for the creative land
trust and you know and people like that
just to come along and give us their
experiences so far as we go along sorry
thank you um uh I think back in April 22
we bought a report to Cabinet
um as part of the approval process for
Grants to be given to third parties and
as part of that we presented uh the
grant agreement that we had drawn up
um our I've got my section 151 officer
sat on my shoulder uh our Auditors both
internal and external are really
watching these programs and we know
um the the way in which government has
given
um Town deal on leveling up funded areas
the money is not is slightly unique in
the way these Grant programs run so we
know that they are watching how we
manage and run these programs and and
the comments earlier about the way we
manage our money is is is true of that
and so one of the things that we did was
he we commissioned a legal team to
develop a grant agreement so that the
council is safeguarded from the risk of
of passing this funding on we are we
become the funder but we're still
responsible to central government and as
part of that any Grant application for a
million pounds or above we are also
bringing in the lawyers to
um put the specifics around those Grant
agreements so that we ensure that that
public money is safeguarded for that
very specific investment
um the Margate creative Land Trust has
already signed their Grant agreement but
they haven't they haven't had big chunks
of money because they are still looking
for the site so we have a particular
drawdown process
each of the projects will be run
differently and the funding will be
allocated differently I I think when
we're talking about big sums of of
capital funding I don't think we are
talking about retrospective funding for
all of it
um and and so it is going to be on an
individual kind of project by project
basis how that is is run and Dreamland
don't have their four million we don't
have dreamlands 4 million that hasn't
been drawn down yet it's not programmed
to be spent within this financial year
and which is why we'll be bringing a
cabinet paper to approve that Grant and
the the grant agreement so all of those
things are kind of happening in due
process
um Town deals across the country are
predominantly projects that are being
delivered by local authorities and or
other big organizations because they're
big sums of capital money and the
Margate Town Deal Board was really clear
that it wanted some Community
um as part of that so even when we had a
reduction in funding from central
government We ensured There were
Community projects within that
um so yes it's really important and
we're working with the skatepark to
think about how they set themselves up
and thinking about how they engage with
other funders and they're doing quite a
lot of that themselves and working
through all of the kind of challenges
each of those different organizations
might be facing I was just trying to
think so we don't we do report on what
has been spent it's it's not huge
amounts at the moment because we haven't
been spending anything on buildings and
assets and as I said as part of that
kind of more simplified approach that
we're trying to take a kind of a higher
level across each of the programs we
want to do a bit more of that it's just
we're still I think we're in our fourth
return for for leveling up and third
in-town deals so we're just trying to
get a bit of balance on those to then be
able to report better back to this going
back to your first question about the
access roads
um we're commissioning a transport study
to make sure that each of the things
that we do the road system works we had
a meeting with the head of highways at
Kent County Council and number one on
our agenda was the tunnel
um and you know I know that we have been
lobbying and pushing really hard for
that and it has to do some of what you
said uh earlier so um yeah
Council payment
yeah thanks Louise um I've got a series
of questions but they're probably short
sharp answers maybe from yourself
um Theater Royal it's good to hear
there's progress being made on the
theater Royal that's really welcomed I
know many performers across sanit and
and people that go to watch performances
will be welcome
um
I know you speak about not something in
the bid but is there a way we can
prioritize our bid over anyone else's
medical standard around the Heritage
funding because there is a real need for
I know we've got the ground view open
that's really great work by TDC in
yourselves but we do need the theater in
Margate as well
um so that's one question Winter Gardens
is that report available the the study
report so we can have a look at that
um and and obviously share kind of views
on that as well
um and is there any scope around future
investment in the Winter Gardens yet is
there like a Clear Vision from your team
around the Winter Gardens
um from all the data that's come out of
that that would be quite good to look at
um my second point is about Dreamland
I'm not overly confident that the future
Dreamland is worth investment of four
million pounds at the moment so I'd like
to see more information around Dreamland
and their future business plans and how
they're going to use the four million
pound to unlock Future investment
because I kind of think there could be
other areas that we could spend it that
would be better invested around leveling
up
and the third question is East Kent
College digital project
work seem to have just stopped and
that's the perception so is there an
update around that
um the grass relationship at the moment
obviously we've had heavy media
attention on the grass relationship so
it'd be good to have an update around
how we're progressing with that because
I know we're all Keen to progress with a
grass relationship
the skate park sorry I said there's a
lot so you know the skate park is there
youth involvement in this I know who
cancel the cup um spoke about the
um youth Council but is there youth
provision in this
and then finally is there a project
around how much is spent and the impact
that that kind of money has had already
on the local economy and things like
that
I know that question but thank you
um so
um I will let you choose between
yourself members which one I put in
first clock house or Theater Royal and
and I'll leave that one there but we are
you know we have to run through a
program of projects and so
um it isn't just other stakeholders but
also I don't we as an organization don't
want to be saying well you can't put
your bidding because we're going to put
ours in and so we've we've worked we've
worked hard to program that we also have
to do a lot of work it isn't just please
National Lottery can we have
um two million three million pounds it's
proving the significance of the Heritage
there's a huge amount of work that needs
to go into that and engagement with
stakeholders so we've got the timing
right and and the work to do within that
uh program
um the evening and nighttime economy uh
review
um I'm actually about to go on holiday
um which is why I've been running around
like a headless chicken but I'm hoping
to have a kind of final final draft
um at the end of next week to look at
when I come back from leave we've had a
lot of Engagement with just some really
interesting stats we've done a lot of
work around footfall and there's things
that we can share with the broader
sector it isn't a document for thanet
district council with a long tick list
of we're going to do all these things
it's it's about what the sector at large
and the council can do together to
improve our evening and nighttime
economy with a particular Focus about
the role of the Winter Gardens within
that but it'll be helpful for the
Granville as well as the theater Royal
um future investment in the Winter
Gardens
um so we have just had the first draft
of our heritage statement for the Winter
Gardens and um it's seven I think it was
70 pages but it's just really
interesting reading and there is some
real interesting opportunities around
that we were talking about briefing the
marketing agency and using some of that
to help that activity all of those
documents will be available we're just
at draft stage so we need to kind of
finalize those but they will all form
part of that pack that goes out to the
sorry broader sector
um Dreamland as I said we're going to be
putting more information online
um I'm meeting with the team
um in in the summer to start thinking
about uh getting those timelines
available and and online and they are
doing some work around their program
um and how I mean a lot of it is about
how it unlocks other investment across
the site uh therefore creating more jobs
and opportunities and town deals were
absolutely about how you unlock private
investment
um there's quite a lot of work going on
that Margate digital I haven't done an
update today just because you know there
was a lot
um but um we are working with ekc group
and Holmes England who we are joint
owners of the the building with there's
been some challenges around the
reclassification of further education
colleges which means they have to do
lease Arrangements different now than
they did when we were about to sign one
in October of last year so we've got a
kind of four-way conversation between
the department of leveling up the
department for Education homes England
that's five us and ekc group and but I'm
happy to bring another update
um
things around grass so they have a grant
agreement which we talked about before
in order to unlock
the capital investment we need that
Grant agreement to be signed
um they've had 25
000 up front to support with project
management costs design costs and all of
those things that can be capitalized
um so we're waiting for that and and the
town Deal Board chair has been engaging
with the organization which is is their
role to to do that so
um I think we will need to wait and see
um skate park I know that they've got
some engagement activities planned I
think this time of year is particularly
busy for them so um we are working with
them to put a program together including
our health and well-being coordinator is
working with them to think about what
activities we can do and it's too early
to measure the impact on the economy
thank you for that really quick response
to really long questions and maybe we
can bring someone from the town Deal
Board in like you said thank you yeah
absolutely definitely uh just one thing
this week I just wanted one thing I want
to pick up I'm sure I've read somewhere
we get a lot of stuff emailed to us I'm
sure I've read somewhere that the
councils are now
gearing up for another round of leveling
up money are we we are we are we look
are we are we are we looking at another
round of leveling up money somewhere
along the line I I just said because you
talked about the Lido and obviously
Walpole Bain how busy that is we've got
other beaches that are really busy like
Westport where we've got a beautiful
logia building you know they're just
saying are we are we looking to to to
put another bid in
um as far as I'm aware there are
currently no announcements on leveling
up round three
um we obviously have asked the question
um and there have been things intimated
that there will be another round
um we have had no Clarity I don't think
uh civil servants are necessarily clear
what that might look like we thought
something might be launched in July
nothing has been launched so I suspect
if there is it'll be after the summer
and we don't know if it will be linked
with previous rounds specific areas
specific themes we don't know
um
we're obviously watching and waiting and
our ambition is large
excellent thank you so uh members
completely forgot where we were so so
this uh report will go to Cabinet do we
have any recommendations
no recommendations okay so um we'll note
that report thank you
okay so I think we just pause a couple
of minutes I'm sure officers want to get
themselves off before we have the next
couple of gender Arts religious
committee discussion so I'm pretty sure
if officers want to leave this is
probably a good idea to go and I thank
you for your coming along this evening
okay so we move on to item number seven
which is the review of the overview
overview and security panel work program
for 23 to 24. we've all had that report
circulated I know we're all gonna have a
bit of a discussion about that now
so members
any questions or comments on the work
report
I think I've said well time what I
wanted to say which is that I am
doubtful about our scoring mechanism
there are elements of it that I don't
think are actually helpful to us in
making the most of our um of our role I
like the way that we've looked at what
things can be done in say an intensive
one day and what things have to be
longer that's really helpful
um we've obviously got a lot of things
that we want to look at and I would like
to argue once again that we need to look
at every meeting at our externally
funded projects in terms of timeline
spend those kinds of things not in terms
of full presentation grateful as I am
for the full presentation this evening
yeah sure so I mean obviously when we in
the report there was a number of topics
that have been picked and we've we've
had to
use the Matrix that we got to to Mark to
score and the officers have scored I
mean I'm not sure is there things on
that list that you were hoping were
going to be that are not there or are
you are you happy that all the topics
are there I'm happy with what I've seen
of the topics uh it was just that I
think that the scoring because we have
prioritized things like what will save
us money and what's been on the list for
a long time I don't think those are
actually helpful looking at the broader
role of the overview bit of overview and
scrutiny that we learned about in the
training sessions which uh which allow
us to to be much more ambitious about
the role of this this panel that's all
foreign
so so looking at the list of all the
topics that were put forward I mean
obviously the list is there I mean
looking at Item B I mean we've had the
update on the externally funded projects
this evening there's obviously two other
things that which we can have to ask
those reports uh going forward but if we
look at the first list the scrutin
review project topics is there anything
that Springs to mind that members would
like to get involved with you know in in
the near term
um on 2.4 a scrutiny review project
topics
and then you've got plenty enforcement
review flytip and abandoned vehicles
reviewer protocols procedures emergency
decisions health and well-being impact
of Tourism go out funding review and the
cost of living crisis
having proposed the planning enforcement
review I think I'd rather like to be
involved with that
um
likewise review of protocols and
procedures for emergency decisions
uh
if that's okay
Council back
sorry I was just picking up on Council
Austin's point just then about
um sort of wider issues and obviously I
wasn't here at the last ones but I
watched it with great interest
um
just thinking of the amount of housing
that's going up
um we looked on planning or planning
last night there was the the small piece
of land that abuts the 1600 House
Development there's a lot of
development going to happen
um obviously we can't look at
infrastructure in terms of I don't know
you talked about this previous in the
previous meeting you talked about
dentists and doctors because we don't
have any control over that one of the
things that did occur to me I was
reading an article today about a big
development I think in Cambridge here
that has thousands of houses and nothing
else other than houses have we got any
kind of thoughts about trying to build
in some sense of community to these new
developments we need the new
developments we need these houses but I
think I don't think a development or an
area becomes a place if it doesn't have
any retail units there or it doesn't
have any pubs there or churches there or
community centers so is there a way that
we can bring
that element to overview and scrutiny
just how we encourage developers of big
of
big developments to think about forming
a community
um whether we use 106 money or what
whatever we use to ensure that there's
some sense of community and some Central
Point to their developments
and yeah that's something you could you
could invite I'm sure uh Bob would uh
tonight yeah well it's not so much
Barbie Bob's team but I'm sure that uh
you could extend an invitation to
probably Adrian and I don't I don't know
why
um then come along speak to the panel on
that issue and then if you wanted to Win
It deeper you could then potentially
complete one of the review forms and
submit it as an idea for a review based
upon the feedback you get from Adrian
I've done it with Bob would wanna
yeah I mean we'd be I think we'd be
happy to come and speak to the panel
from an officer perspective about the
work that we're doing
um but yeah if you you might want others
to external organizations to speak to
you and you can always invite them
um you know obviously whether they come
or not it's a matter for them but
um we would certainly be happy to come
and talk to you about the work that
we're doing ourselves
the local Plan update cabinet advisor
group starting up again soon I know
you're the chair the cancer yeah I mean
I was going to say
obviously scrutiny can call what he
wants to call
to scrutiny within the Constitution but
I think possibly a better place for that
work is the local plan
um review Group which is
less formal
um and purely focused on planning
matters obviously so um maybe you want
to see how that group evolves and it
will be meeting soon
um decision notice is going to be issued
imminently and then maybe think about
whether you want to involve Security in
it
I was just going to say that obviously
obviously was hoping that some of that
sort of discussion would happen in the
in the debate that we have in October
around our proposal to pause planning
for large
um developments pending a review the
review to consider some of the sorts of
elements that Council bright was talking
about
um I'd like to be involved in health and
well-being it's obviously on my area of
interest I'm not sure how I looked to
make a long meeting any longer but I'm
not sure if you're aware that ccg
framework um changed last July so we no
longer have commissioning care groups
and it changed to integrated Care
Systems they're about 37 covering
um England and there's a trend now
towards devolving some more of that
money towards social care into local
government so I think that's just
something we should be aware of moving
forward as well yeah sure I think their
health and well-being topic is very
broad I think it encompasses housing and
everything else we was going to bring
into that I think but yeah certainly if
we take that topic forward then yeah we
certainly can be a part of that I think
I think what we need to do is pick maybe
three for this year I was like it's
gonna I Think We're not gonna get more
than three done in in over the course of
a year and I think we need to pick three
I know
I have my favorite one but I know we
need to discuss it amongst ourselves I
know the impact of Tourism is quite
broadly welcomed last time which is
something I'd like to look at but
so
can I remind members that maybe this
discussion would better be helped by
looking at the annex other thing is
annex too to this uh to this report
so that members can either either
discard or rearrange what because these
are the topics that members came up with
which we then prioritized but it's up to
members to rearrange them in the manner
they like but these are virtually the
topics that they said these are the
topics would like to work on for this
year
next
just to I mean I was going to say
something similar with
put forward and we have put them all
forward it doesn't also topics
Elvis has scored them to our agreed
scoring system
surely we we should go with that new
topics are all very well and we can talk
about them down the line but let's at
least get
the first two or three
topics on on agendas
um
through the scoring system now I happen
to think that this our scoring system
works against
broader topics
it's more focused on
stuff that's
directly related to the council not to
the general area so perhaps we could
discuss that at some point down the line
but but for now
let's stick to what we've got with the
scoring system
yeah definitely Council green I did I
have had the discussion with Negan to
put scoring as an agenda item for a
future date to when we look at topics
again but I think if we work with the
the list we've got as I say so I just I
think we just between us picked the the
three the top three out of that list
maybe I don't know all work the way down
it's I remember how they want to do it
um just on the uh the rankings that are
currently there I would like to formally
propose that we look at three subjects
then with regards to these rankings and
given the the time that you think that
we've got in this year to to look at
those so uh the first in the priority is
the impact of Tourism
um then the fly typing abandoned
vehicles
and then the grant funding review
um
as ranked and I think that they have
been ranked in that order and that's
what I propose those three obviously
other members are able to propose others
but I just thought I'd get the ball
rolling on those thank you chair so just
go out funding
impact decision what was the third one
fly tip okay
does anybody want to change that or
agree with that
I've got a second I've got loads of
secondaries and Dave Cancer Day
burning him sorry
planning enforcement review
there was a planning review
in progress before but it fizzled into
nothing December late last year there
are a huge number of issues particularly
with planning enforcement which is why
I'd raised it when I did and I
understand and I support the point
scoring system I don't think we're that
far a drift on that and given that it's
been on the program that doesn't count
as being on the program for Point
scoring I think that should be allocated
and we should include it in the three
please
obviously but
um
so if I um if I just suggest something
that I mean look oh I'm sure that if we
invite uh Ian along as a as an
alternative to
doing a review to come along an update
on where we're at with playing
enforcement
is that yeah
um well yeah of course you know if you
invite Ian and myself along to talk
about planning enforcement we'd happily
do that
um there was previously a planning
enforcement review
um and that led to some changes to the
planning enforcement protocol so there
were some there were some outcomes of
that
um but you know let's not say you
shouldn't have a look at it again if you
want to
um that's very interesting because given
the amount of cases and the evidence
that we're dealing with at the moment
it's good that there was an outcome and
some some stronger protocols but I'd now
question that whether they need to be
reviewed or the implementation of them
looks at because of the number of cases
that there are that are not just not
proceeding or not being dealt with
adequately
which one of the three do you want to
drop off to replace with the with the
planning enforcement One
impact of Tourism fly tipping and
abandoned vehicles and the grant funding
review
does
[Music]
right so we've got a proposition that we
drop off impact of Tourism and put in a
planning enforcement does anybody want
to second that
so we continue with the three that we've
that we've agreed and then we'll invite
someone from in planning enforcement to
come along at a future meeting to give
us a full Rundown
that's not what we were going there
could could we could I suggest uh
another uh process so if we've agreed
those three can we then make us another
another proposal to say that if we are
in a position where we have uh
undertaken those three
can we ensure that the planning
enforcement review is the next on the
list if we have the time to do so
well of course because we're going to
work on this list anyway so yeah that
would automatically hit up to members
then to choose the next the next ones
going forward but I think if we've got a
proposition we've got a second uh we had
an amendment that nobody seconded
so I think going forward the three that
we're going to choose are impact of
Tourism
um
grant funding review and the Flight of
The Fly tipping so
a councilor coming I was going to say
split wear things that were requested
for officer reports and to just ask how
they will be progressed and is there a
timeline on
the reports obviously we progressed one
tonight
and then we we can look at a future
meeting I think we've been looking at a
different one for the next meeting but I
think we can definitely get these onto
the future meetings for presentation
from officers yeah I think I'm obviously
going to maybe able to plan the
enforcement before that but
[Applause]
that's right
out so Austin with all due respect I
think that getting a presentation from
an officer about planning is a very
different matter from looking at a
planning enforcement review I think
they're two separate things I'm that's
no not in any way to decry officer
presentations but I don't think it does
as I as I understand I don't think it's
going to do what council Davis is
concerned it should do
I don't think I think I agree with with
councilor Austin however if if it got us
started on the topic and then it may
inform future activity so long as that's
the case if it's not a case of well he's
spoken so that's it it could be that
that presentation leads to a request for
further activity yeah yeah that was my
suggestion just to buy it over in the
time sorry if I appear a bit thick I'm
just clarifying where we are with it so
counselor green
that suggestion coupled with the site of
the previous yeah review which wasn't
that long ago
um
could could help to bring that together
I agree so we've got the three going
forward impact of Tourism
fly tip in
and go out funding in that order
okay so we will look
to set up working groups for those three
going forward or do we want to set up a
group tonight
well uh we can do one
idea so obviously it's cost party
working group so how many
people would you like on it we've got
two from each group two greens two two
vegetables
or three
okay
the total size you'd probably want five
things so for
the impact of Tourism do we have
volunteers for the working group
one two
three I was looking at you George
because you
there's three everybody else
counselor going oh we've got five all
right there you go sorry cancer
that's all settled in so we have our
first review group working group
settled on the impact of Tourism
going forward Okay so
so we all agree
okay thank you
and item eight the last one of the
evening of losing track now after being
here for three hours
um as everybody looked at the forward
planning exempt decision list is there
anybody wish to make a comment
no okay so can we all councilor green
well that's almost impossible to know
what it's talking about exactly yeah
yeah yeah
so that concludes the business for
tonight's meeting a very long meeting I
thank you all for coming thank you all
to the offices thank you to the cabinet
members and uh and good night